we got a lot of crazy news my friends
Mark milley confirms the quote-unquote
treason phone call with China which I
would say uh colloquially in the
personal sense uh yeah treason he
betrayed this country he called all
China's military and said everything
you're doing every con here's what
happened Mark milley's like hey you ever
see that Tim pool guy's show you know he
won't shut up about the acidity's Trap
and the fear that there's gonna be a war
between the two Nations don't worry
we'll never attack you
after everything China has done Mark
milley and October called them and said
don't worry your pretty little faces
about it which basically gave them carte
blanche and then they continued to put
pressure over the past year in the South
China Sea sink in Vietnamese fishing
boats as they've been doing now they're
now they're being seen up in Alaska
because Mark belly is like don't worry
and even if we do attack you we'll give
you advanced warning Millie then had
according to this report a a secret
meeting to subvert the chain of command
the hill reported this saying he had a
meeting with senior official officers
telling them to report to him to try and
circumvent Donald Trump's orders as
president which Alexander vindman of all
people said is usurping civilian
Authority and we heard from the dod in
the New York Times story would be a
military coup now that's big news right
but we didn't lead with that you know
why
because we were just talking about this
later before I turn the camera on
Breitbart said that politics is
Downstream from culture I think politics
is irrelevant to culture is everything
and the cultural story is that Nicki
Minaj has been suspended from Twitter
she's a massive celebrity with Matt with
tons of 22 million followers and
probably Millions more fans and she re
she was retweeting Tucker Carlson
she was calling the media Liars
what happens she gets suspended
so I don't know if this is going to be
any uh big wake-up moment for a lot of
people I mean Kanye West came out and
was spitting facts at a lot of people as
well as you know some crazy stuff that's
Kanye and maybe this won't be the
biggest story compared to like a general
staging a coup against the president but
how many people in this country are
sitting there going like did you hear
about Mark Milly staging a coup and how
many are like yo they suspended Nicki
Minaj what
how many people heard what she had to
say it had a big impact so we got to
talk a lot about this we got to talk
about politics and culture we mentioned
it on the past few nights that politics
doesn't even matter at this point I
don't even I don't even you know what
I'm thinking about it what's the point
right we got all these old laws there's
like funny books called like old laws
still in effect like you can't bake an
apple pie on Sundays and put it on your
windowsill in Massachusetts and it's
like well of course no cop will ever
enforce that why because our culture
changed we no longer care and it would
be ridiculous so even with the law on
the books doesn't even matter with
judges in the Supreme Court it doesn't
even matter
so let's talk about it right now Jack
Murphy what's up everybody it is a
Wednesday which means 50 50 chance I'll
be here on timcast heads I call heads
here we are thank you for having me I
appreciate it I have so much to say
about what you just said right there but
first thing I want to do is invite
everyone to come have a jack brunch with
me on Sunday 9 26 in New York City we
did an event actually it's gonna be in
Jersey City just so you know forget the
vax mandates forget the vax cards forget
all that we're not going to New York
City we're going to Jersey City one stop
outside of New York City no vax mandates
no vax mandates vote with your dollars
could have done that he certainly could
he still can he still could have uh we
have fans of Jersey City and in New York
city so we're going to Jersey City to
get everybody there we had an event in
Chicago uh last week it was tremendous
it is open to everyone women and
children wives and girlfriends men and
boys so please come down look it up
jackedbrunch.com or follow us on Twitter
at Jack brunch we're going to New York
next weekend we're going to Tampa we're
going to Nashville Austin Denver Seattle
New York La San Francisco we're going
all over the place you guys are going to
come you're going to come in DC we're
going in February on February 27 2022
you all are invited you're gonna come to
brunch is that a weekend it is a Sunday
yeah yeah jacked brunch check it out
Jack brunch.com follow me on Twitter at
Jack brunch what's your name I am Ian
Crossland Ian Arthur Crossland Ian
Arthur middle name is Art I had no idea
I was named after like my grandma's
brother you're Ian iak Yak I used to
think that that went through my mind a
lot when I was young yeah yeah why
couldn't my last name started with an N
yeah you'd be e and if
that's so cool
Jack I'm so glad you're back I am too I
like how that rhyme every other
Wednesday is my favorite Wednesday
that's right it's so relaxed you know it
is no pressure yeah we're absolutely
just chilling I love when Jack's here we
always get up to no good and he always
enjoys uh our beverages we do we have a
very fine whiskey right here today with
a scotch whiskey actually we have a
Highland Park the dark 17 year old
how is it it is fantastic very cool Tim
sent me a message the other day and he
texted me he's like dude we got a 40
year old scotch for you that's not it
that's not it I'm like the 40-year one
is
we got we got some 25s there's a pair of
vans on the floor but there's no 40 40
year Scotch over here it was it
surprisingly wasn't that expensive well
it tastes like it well no that one I
mean it's a couple hundred bucks I think
that one goes from like 300 to 500 or
whatever but we the the and the 40-year
is comparable but we've got some really
expensive stuff even though I don't
drink because you know we want to we
gotta take care of our guests we don't I
feel very well taken care I just want
everyone to know we don't pay the people
who show up here oh no can't can confirm
uh yeah nope nope and that's our
business so anyway anyway we can at
least give them some some some good
whiskeys it's delicious and Lydia I'm
looking over there I can see the henta
on your hand is that from the wedding
yeah so I I got um henna from my
sister's wedding she's married into an
Indian family it's very cool very
traditional what is henna Hannah's like
this brown dye they make it with uh
leaves and it's like the super super old
tradition they pound it down they add a
little bit of water and turns into like
this oil-based weird stuff that stays on
for like two weeks it's actually pretty
impressive I have a quick question about
your friend your your brother uh new
brother-in-law and a wedding uh I went
to an Indian wedding once on the
invitation it said wedding starts at 6
p.m so me and the three other Caucasians
that were attending this wedding we
showed up at 6 p.m for this wedding no
one else showed up for literally two
hours that that you what you're doing
right now as white supremacy oh my God
that's right punctuality punctuality I
mean Indian weddings are an impressive
spectacle yeah so there were a couple
different ceremonies and the the second
one that I attended everybody was not
punctual but no one was two hours late
the pictures were beautiful thank you
okay it looked really fun yeah right on
well Lydia of course is pressing all the
buttons I am yes that's what I'm doing
over here but before we get started we
have an amazing sponsor my friends go to
strongerbonesandlife.com to get bio
trusts ageless multi-collagen we have it
right here Ian literally just put some
in his water and your water's clear yeah
wow it was amazing I watched that
dissolve into my water it's really cool
you see like you see holes start to this
yeah it sounds amazing this is a
collagen is what you need for your
joints your skin your lips your face
makes your skin look Supple and young so
go to stronger bones in life.com if you
want to get this stuff now for me I
skate all the time I skateboard been
rollerblading a bit more having a lot of
fun doing big airs and all that stuff
that means as an old man in this world
I've got it yeah I've been putting this
stuff in my coffee I've been putting we
got the other stuff the MCT oil stuff
but I've been making sure that I'm
eating better eating healthier so go to
strongerbones in life.com get your
BioTrust Angels multi multi-calogen
collagen and you get 60 day money back
guarantee the five key types of collagen
you need from four different sources if
for every order today BioTrust will
donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provide over 5 million
meals to Hungry kids please help them
hit their goal of 6 million meals this
year the Ageless multi-calogen is
non-GMO free of artificial colors
flavors preservatives and sweeteners
free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and
RBST nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements
there's no clumping as Ian just showed
you with his Crystal Clear looking water
free shipping with every order free VIP
live health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order again
BioTrust shout out thank you so much for
sponsoring the show go to strongerbones
in life.com and can I add I didn't even
Stir It it dissolved on its own and I
was I jumped on the trampoline today and
when I got off I was walking up the
steps and I felt a pain in my knee the
first thing that went through my mind
was I hope we're doing College in a
night yeah bio trust come on people
don't realize that Ian's 50. 57. I'll be
59 tomorrow yeah and I thought I was the
old man just just keep living man you'll
get there just because there's probably
some people have never heard the show or
something and they're like wow no Ian's
not 50. no I'm not 50. I'm 42. he may be
wearing pajamas and sometimes we have to
wipe his nose but he's not 50. thank you
Jack and don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member we are uh we are we
we've been doing meetings for the new
show which I think is we're getting
ready to launch the Mysteries show
really soon
um it requires development on the
website to create a new space for it we
don't want Mysteries like podcasts to
mix up with with news and news feeds so
we're creating this unique layout for
all of our new shows it's going to look
like any other streaming service where
it's like the shows are there and you
can you know swipe so we're building
that out and we have a couple of
episodes already ready to go well I'm
ready to go air quotes like we've been
producing them I'll put it that way and
so it's coming soon uh but you will get
the members only segment tonight so make
sure you subscribe support our
journalists become a member of all this
stuff but like this channel subscribe to
this channel too share the show with
your friends if everybody
watching right now took the URL put it
on their social media Facebook Twitter
or whatever it is you mines gab or
whatever we'd be bigger than CNN
overnight no joke you're already bigger
than MSNBC no question about that but on
TV they get YouTube ratings too because
they're propped up by The Establishment
that's right so I mean it's true in the
key demo like we absolutely roast the
cable trip the cable shows like not not
even like double but when it comes to
them getting from the front page by
YouTube they get hundreds of millions
you can't do anything about it one share
we can share one last comment I just got
a text from my wife to be she says I
take collagen I'm a cool kid too she
literally just texted perfect she's
watching it at home dude that stuff is
great I was just looking at it in my
water when it dissolves in it
what a look I mean it looks so cool
that's great let's let's talk about Miss
Nicki Minaj or is it is it is it Mrs
Nicki Minaj she married she had a baby
so this this just happened like
literally as we were sitting down I was
like Mark milley traitor to the United
States when I'm slamming the table down
and then we're like oh Lydia's like
Nicki Minaj was suspended I was like oh
this takes precedence yes now um I don't
think it's necessarily more important
than Mark Milly a general calling China
and giving them warning about U.S you
know uh plans but I do think this is
significant one we're seeing a celebrity
for those that have been following Nicki
Minaj is tweeting about the vaccine
she's being lied about left and right in
the media and I think this is a major
what should I say um what was that movie
where the guy was in the computer and
then there were two pills and one of
them woke him up whatever that was it's
about a word I can't say on this thing
here no you can say red pill so it's a
major I was making a joke it's a major
red pill moment for a lot of people to
see Nicki Minaj being like hey they're
lying about me she is married by the way
all right on Mrs Nicki Minaj and uh the
same thing happened with Kanye Kanye
comes out and says something reasonable
and also the media lies about everything
so Kanye came out I don't know if you
guys saw this and he was talking about
the 13th Amendment the 13th amendment
allows slavery in the event of a
criminal conviction and so Kanye was
like we got to do away with that and
they were like Kanye calls for
reinstating slavery or something and
he's like dude like they really go over
the top with it so we have this tweet I
just picked up whatever random verified
Twitter user who had tweeted about it
okay who had Nicki Minaj getting locked
out of her Twitter account after
reposting a four reposting Tucker
Carlson on their 2021 bingo card and he
won
Nicki Minaj we got some tweets from her
so see uh okay so uh Stephen Colbert's
show oh actually it looks like CNN
actually said this
all right we gotta slow down this is
this is this is a crazy story fast
developing Nicki Minaj tweeted that her
cousin didn't want to get the vaccine
because his friend got the vaccine and
his balls swole up and then he became
impotent and his fiancee called off
their wedding
it's probably a ridiculous story I don't
think it's true I bet it is true it's
it's horribly hilarious okay but but but
true in the sense like did the vaccine
have anything to do all right that's no
that there's nothing on theirs like the
vaccine adverse event where they're like
my balls are huge like no so she tweeted
this thing out and the media then
started claiming here's what they said
in this uh CNN clip they said she cited
that reason as to why she's not getting
vaccinated which is not true now I gotta
say
I got I actually had uh let's say a
minor argument with the people with with
our our friends over at timcast.com
talking about the article that was
written up because the original headline
was like Nicki Minaj says she won't get
vaccinated to attend the Met Gala or
something and then people were like
that's not a fair headline and I I don't
agree with the framing either and we
talked about it so here's what's true
Nicki Minaj said the Met Gala wants you
to get vaccinated if I'm gonna get
vaccinated it's not gonna be for the Met
Gala and so the headline used on timcast
was Nicki Minaj refuses to get vaccine
for Met Gala and I'm like
technically accurate yeah but I don't
like that because Nicki Minaj said that
the reason she's not traveling is
because she had a baby
and then she mentioned she's not getting
she's not going that the Met Gala wanted
the vaccines and if she was going to get
the vaccine it wouldn't be for them this
title I feel like makes it seem like she
didn't go to the Met Gala because she
didn't want to get vaccinated and so we
discussed it and it's like look the
headline is true she said she wouldn't
get vaccinated for the Met Gala like I
don't know what how else we should frame
it like make a really long headline and
I'm like all right whatever I defer to
your judgment but some people in the
comments posted something and I'm like
good you know I'll let that beat on my
phone Nicki Minaj won't punch a vax
ticket to attend Met Gala
punch a vax ticket yeah you know get
your backs done just saying you can
condense it there was a way to do it but
I hear what you're saying I guess the
issue is you need the proper context
yeah the reason she didn't go she stated
some before any of this controversy
somebody was like why haven't you done
an appearance in a year she was I just
had a baby I'm not traveling then when
they're like the Met Gala she said they
require of X-Men it I wouldn't get it
for them anyway but if you look at the
full context of what she's been saying
she didn't go not because of the vaccine
she even said she would get one to go on
tour she didn't go because she's got a
kid and she doesn't want to travel oh so
now they're claiming one of the reasons
she won't get vaccinated is because she
because of swollen testicles Stephen
Colbert did a whole bit this is the
crazy thing that people need to
understand when Sarah Palin was was you
know running with uh with McCain Tina
Fey who I think Tina Fey's brilliant did
this bit where she's like I can see
Russia from my house
Sarah Palin ever said anything like that
that's ridiculous what Sarah Palin did
say was something like you know you know
in terms of foreign policy you can
actually see Russia from the westernmost
point of Alaska and we actually have to
negotiate with them on the straight on
trade so I think you know this is you
know A major benefit for the office of
the presidency and I'm like it's
actually a really great Point as
governor of Alaska you have that trade
route that goes between the Bering
Strait or whatever and that means she
has to work with Russia what happens a
bunch of my friends are like oh man the
Sarah Palin thinks she could see Russia
from her house or so I'm like dude that
was that was Tina Fey like that wasn't
that wasn't real and that's what we have
going on right now so now
because I think this is important for
one we got uh let me shout out some of
these people one person responded with
uh because because Nicki Minaj posted uh
Tucker Carlson and actually did I pull
that one up okay I don't have that one
she posted Tucker Carlson oh wait I do
have I do it yeah with a bullseye it's a
bullseye over Tucker Carlson's content
and Hassan the son says you know he's a
white nationalist right okay Tucker
Carlson is not a white nationalist
that's a lie
um and so Nicki Minaj responded to him
and other people saying like dude I can
point out when someone's telling the
truth that doesn't make me political or
whatever and then here's the crazy thing
when multiple news outlets lied about
like the swollen testicles thing she
said y'all are lying about me and people
started saying Nikki's on the side of
the far right so she you know she's
wrong
if you question the media you're far
right that's far right now yeah well
look Nikki Nikki is in trouble from the
jump you know why because she's Young
Money young money Lil Wayne Lil Wayne
Donald Trump yeah
yeah oh for real she's in Young Money
with with Drake and uh and Lil Wayne and
Nikki and it's very clear Lil Wayne is a
trump guy they're clearly on a different
tip whatever tip that is they're on
their own one and I thought it was
admirable actually what she said which
is that like I'm not traveling because I
have a baby and I may or may not get the
vaccine but I sure as heck aren't
getting the vaccine just to go to some
stupid party with some lady wearing
tacks of rich on her butt
so to me I mean that all adds up I do
not listen to her music I probably don't
appreciate her value so much but at the
same time I can see how her associations
and her willingness to question the
narratives and her willingness to just
speak her mind
wasn't she the one that like saw like
her tax bill one day or whatever she's
just like going off on the taxes I mean
that all makes perfect sense to me these
are just things normal people say why is
she being singled out because she's got
millions and millions of followers
because yeah these are just random
thoughts man the media is a swamp of
full of well I don't know if piranhas
live in the swamps or like rivers in the
rainforest but it is a swamp somewhere
bad with some kind of swamp piranha and
if you uh you know look Nicki Minaj
comes out and she said you know they
don't they don't care about anything she
says until she said pray on it and make
the choice for yourself as we often say
and that is the No-No the No-No phrase I
mean look it stop me if I go down the
road I'm not allowed to go down but the
bottom line for me is that I have come
to understand that this is a personal
choice and frankly
you know I don't know where this is
going to go because you know I'm
sensitive to all these things because I
don't want to say the wrong thing I'm
being censored I'm censoring myself okay
that's Humanity you got to sense
yourself a little bit as you go the
point is it's like look it is it is a
personal decision that's now not being
allowed to be a personal decision and
that is pretty much the bottom line when
I when I think about it and I think
about whether or not I should do it for
myself or my kids should do it for
themselves
those are independent questions if
somebody is bullying me into doing it my
first instinct is just be like nope I
think the vaccine mandates do that just
know tons not bullying me tons of people
tweeting not because of the Mandate okay
I forget to Spill the bottle tons of
people tweeting now because of the
Mandate never going anywhere near any of
this stuff yeah and you know what the
response on the left is like well you
were never going to do it anyway and no
that's not true I wouldn't seriously
consider I have all of my vaccines I
just got a pertussis booster oh my right
like I had to do that when my kids were
being bored it's like your moms are the
mother-in-laws the moms they all had to
get a pertussis booster just to come in
and see the baby no one batted an eye at
that right here's here's the issue
when someone is like after 28 years of
research and we have this vaccine or
whatever or decades and then we've come
to a legislative decision after many
votes and many hearings on it that's the
key phrase legislative decision right
well when when I elect somebody and they
say we're going to have a hearing in the
you know senate committee on X and it's
having to do with vaccines I'm like
these are all normal processities that I
can watch on TV you can hear the
arguments and then there's a vote on it
and it's put through a legislative
process I'm like you got it when there's
when there's long-term data and stuff so
here's my issue right now is a vaccine
mandate by decree get out of my face
well not playing well no no no no no
because you shut up Ian because I want
to let you finish your thoughts there's
no medical exemptions there's no
religious exemptions and now you can see
the government is giving exemptions only
when they're scared like so the Postal
Service no that's not true that was that
was that was debunked oh was it yeah
sorry but the nurses in New York they
were running short on nurses because
nurses were refusing to get vaccinated
and then uh the courts reversed it so
okay if you're a medical worker you're
good now because they were like people
are quitting in this critical
infrastructure I'll put it this way when
someone's like we have a hundred we have
hundreds of years of data on like polio
and kids have like a 20 chance of like
disability and like by the time you're
50 you know you're negatively impacted
and we have this vaccine fine after a
long period of time
that I get when an executive just comes
out and says it and we have no long-term
health effects or risk for for pregnancy
because the FDA insert doesn't include
it's like we don't have data on that I
can respect someone saying I'm gonna
wait you can't come to me and try and
get in between me and my doctor that's
my problem with this that it's like I I
honestly I think the vaccines are safe
you know I don't believe a lot of the
the the high you know stressed out
sensationalism you hear like swollen
balls or whatever I don't believe it
sorry I certainly think there can be
Adverse Events and some of them probably
rare and extreme don't get me wrong but
regardless I'm gonna do my research I'm
gonna go talk to my doctor what do we
have now leftists these people claiming
to be libertarian socialists or anything
but walking in between me and my doctor
and saying shut up don't listen to him
go get the vaccine and I'm like can you
get out of my way so I can ask this guy
like what he thinks because you know
Howard Stern comes out and he's like Joe
Rogan's doctors are [ __ ] for
prescribing him this medication and I'm
like Howard Stern you're not a doctor
how are we going to sit here and have
them say you're not a doctor you didn't
do research and then I'm like neither
did you
so when I when I tweeted
don't just pull into a parking lot go
talk to your doctor get him on the phone
ask him the questions you got to ask
them people were like why would you do
that you're scaring people I'm like yo
literally people on the left telling me
that I was wrong to suggest people talk
to their doctor
that's where we're at so a few things
there one the thing that comes to mind
first and foremost here is that there
was no legislative process
okay requiring all corporations of 100
employers or more to have their
employees be vaccinated sounds to me
like a law
right and a law should be negotiated
discussed debated in public and voted
upon by your representatives that you
send to Congress because it's going to
affect basically everybody 80 million
people I think is what the target was
with that 100 million 100 and uh and up
incorporation I think they said it'll
affect 100 million 100 million great
yeah so what if this is is a prime
example of the way that the
administrative State and the Judiciary
have stripped the legislation
legislature of all their power and
basically ended our democracy okay you
have administrative State executive
branch agencies that create a rule then
they they it basically becomes law then
somebody files a lawsuit and the judge
rules on whether or not that law is
right that is how or whether or not that
rule is right that is how laws are being
made in America today independent of the
legislature we do not have a democracy
that it is gone the Republic is gone yes
when the executive branch administrative
offices can make a rule someone can
protest it in the courts and the courts
rule on its validity and then it becomes
law that way that means our Republic is
dead it is dead it is gone it is history
and we now must move into a phase what
I've been calling now refound or die so
so what kind of government do we have
we have a technocracy it's it's not a
technocracy
um you know technocracy typically is a
reference to rule by technology right no
no no by technocrats by people who
believe they're experts in their field
that they can scientific method their
way to Perfection that they can resolve
all human conflict and issues if we just
try harder legislate harder administer
harder that's that's not what we have
well that's what the vaccine is it's a
piece of science technocracy is
typically reference to like you know a
rule by those of of of science Google
technology Facebook yeah
no no but Joe Biden making an OSHA rule
is in technocracy it's something else
it's it's akin to like so tyranny yes
let's let's break this down in the in
the classically liberal Democratic
fashion our government works uh as such
we we elect a representative for our
area they go and have a meeting where
they draft a bill say we want this to be
law that goes goes from their committees
into the greater chamber where they vote
on it and then the Executive Signs off
on it or vetoes it if there's a veto and
this is how Most states work and how the
federal government works if they veto it
then you need a greater majority in the
legislation to overrule him
here's how it works today the executor
the executive The Sovereign drafts a
rule to the people saying You must
comply and the people are are allowed
only if negative negatively impacted to
question that law and then the courts as
you mentioned will weigh as to whether
or not the negative impact is is
Justified is is would justify striking
down the executive decree that's very
very different from my representative
drafts a bill he goes to committee
there's a debate on it there's hearings
we're at the point right now where
Joe Biden has done this on more than one
occasion completely shutting out the
legislative judicial branches
Cuomo did the same thing so it's more of
you can argue that what we still get to
elect the president or whatever sure
fine but that doesn't change the fact
that we're not there's no Dem there's no
democracy when it when you you appoint
an a sovereign
it's basically electing a king is what
we're doing we're electing a king every
four years a guy that can just make
decrees he can make decrees that are
backed up by his minions and backed up
by the courts and the police and the
police it's uh it's really frustrating
and sad and scary if you want to really
learn about it look up Dr Marini this
guy has written in tremendous amount on
the administrative State and there's it
happens in every domain it happens in
education it happens in finance it
happens in healthcare it happens in
security it happens in policing it
happens everywhere
and it's just it's literally getting
worse each pres I don't know the SATs on
this but I'm I'm assuming this is right
each of the president is increasingly
using executive orders on top of to best
the guy before him more executive boards
more executive boards more executive
orders and with Congress at its stand
still there's no legislation one last
point on this when the legislator was
founded legislature was founded in
America they would the the details on
the laws would be like 600 tons of this
42 tons of that a thousand feet of this
10 miles of that they were as specific
as possible now it's just like you know
protect the workers and then let the
administrative State figure out how to
do that now it's uh disorderly conduct
you can be arrested for anything yeah
the cops can walk up and be like you're
being disorderly you're obstructing
justice but let's let's talk about the
process by which this vaccine minute can
be implemented right so a Ben Shapiro
tweeted there's no force in this country
it's going to be able to implement
Biden's vaccine mandate you know once
your company is 100 people then you
gotta test weekly
there is there are edges there is a
force that can do it for one yes if they
do bounties you know if they're like
snitch on your your company and we'll
give you a reward but it's very it's
really simple I mean it's the IRS
it's the IRS simply says every year when
you file paperwork for each employee you
have to include their their proof of
vaccination with your tax return and if
they're not vaccinated your weekly test
of theirs which is 52 per employee times
100 which is just a ridiculous cost at a
baseline a baseline And if you don't if
you miss one or lose one fourteen
thousand dollar fine and it's going to
be on you per Incident That's what I'm
saying if you have 52 per person and you
miss one 14 Grand imagine you've got an
envelope full of the with all the papers
for the 52 weeks of proof and then your
dog eats it well there's 52 times 14 000
they're in a taxi for your small
business or a large business
now here's the question
do you think law enforcement will come
out to serve uh seat property seizures
and arrest warrants for tax evasion when
the io they don't have to they don't
have to you know what they can just lean
your account without doing it without
even police action they just no no I I
understand your finances but I'm asking
if tax evasion is is you're criminally
charged yeah because what happens is you
you get fined you know the IRS finds you
uh you know 15 grand right 14 Grand and
you don't pay it and they say you know
you're in debt and then you try to get
around it so then they put the pressure
on you I'm not saying they would do this
they can enforce it this way but I'm
just saying if a warrant was issued due
to failure to pay taxes or some some
criminal liability to find within the
tax code do you think that cop is going
to be like for the vaccine mandate
that's wrong or they're going to be like
tax avoider of course tax avoider yep
yeah they just get their marching orders
and they go do it and they probably
won't even get an order to be like this
is for the max the vaccine this is just
a taxable they're going to say this is a
business who owes us 200 000 taxes
they've been avoiding they've been given
multiple warnings we've seized their
assets but now they're trying to
obfuscate their debts
how about this what happens if a company
tries arguing that oh this is the proof
of vaccination and they say oh that's
fake right so so I I've been a bunch of
points I remember in the in the late 90s
my first job was working for a
consulting company that was still doing
Savings and Loan bailout work from the
80s so an entire industry was built
around what happened with the savings
loans in the 80s an entire industry has
just been born
just been birthed around the vaccine
mandate around around vaccine compliance
around vaccine audits around uh testing
Audits and like all the and negotiating
and litigating like that this is a
massive industry that was just created
overnight and there's a thousand million
Consultants out there chomping at the
bit to start their own business about in
this field but the thing that troubles
me the most about this is that Biden
knows that he has no legal
constitutional standing to do what he's
doing and the way that you can tell that
is that each part of their plan is like
comes out of one weird obscure angle one
bit comes out of Osha another bid on the
housing part comes out of the CDC makes
no sense it doesn't make any sense and
all of it says is that they pretextually
need want to accomplish something
and then they go about finding the way
to get that done rather than using their
constitutionally granted powers to exert
the things that they've been elected to
do the whole thing is a freaking joke
the whole thing is tyranny we are not
living in a republic you do not have the
choice your representatives did not
debate this there was no debate on the
floor there was no vote you did not
consent to this and now it is being
enforced upon you and it's not going to
be
by a gun it's going to be by liens and
seizures right they're just going to
snatch your stuff they're gonna you're
gonna have your bank you're gonna have
to hire lawyers and accountants to fight
this back your second amendment rights
don't have anything to do here you're
not going to be able to defend yourself
with your AR-15 against an oncoming
onslaught of police coming to get your
stuff you're gonna have to hire AR-15
worth of lawyers and accountants to
protect yourself you can't defend your
your bank account with a gun right
that's what I'm saying you have to your
second amendment here is being able to
hire lawyers
bring a lot of higher accountants to
defend you from these liens and seizures
that are going to come 14 000 per
incident and so what I believe would end
up happening is take a look at the
eviction moratorium stuff it's gonna be
it's going to be cops enforcing this and
they're gonna say dude I don't know what
you're talking about this says failure
to appear this you know you you would
have summons this says tax evasion
you're a criminal I have a story just
like this I when I got doxed in 2018
I was in an ongoing online dispute with
my former employer and I tweeted out to
them I said you think I'm going to go
into the dark quietly I'm going to burn
this whole thing down figuratively of
course it was figuratively it was
singing the blues okay what happens at
11 o'clock at night Bang Bang Bang Bang
Bang on my door
like I'm in bed my kids are in bed I go
downstairs freaking butt naked and there
are two detectives with the with the
badges hanging around their neck and a
bulletproof vest and and the
windbreakers on and they had eight and a
half by eleven printed out a sheet that
just said I'm going to burn this whole
thing down I was like what are you here
for what are you here for the tweets
dude we're here for the tweets
we're here for the tweets they didn't
know why they got sent they didn't know
the context they didn't know that I was
an ongoing dispute they didn't know that
I was a writer they didn't know that I
was literary in my word usage they just
had a tweet and they don't care and an
eight and a half and eleven blow up of
my driver's license and they were just
like this is this you yes did you say
this yes step outside
that's what's gonna happen a million
times over and over again
it's scary
yep so uh they can't enforce it
and I think you know people shouldn't
get caught up in this one particular
thing either the eviction moratorium was
government theft of property at a
national level government theft of
property and you end up with the here's
why I'll tell you this
there's there's a lot of hit pieces
that'll come out be like Tim pool claims
to be Center left and it's like well
yeah because I can literally talk about
my policy positions and what that means
for being left libertarian but is Hassan
the son a left libertarian no he's in
favor of the government seizing your
property of the government The Authority
taking property from the working class
away from them he's in favor of
executive decree mandating people be
medicated same thing is true for vosh
they're not Libertarians they can you
know respect for foster coming on the
show and having these debates but he
says he's a Libertarian socialist no he
isn't he celebrates the government
mandating forced medication on the
people okay now I get it if it's a
legislative decision there's a
democratic process of Liberty where it's
like we've come together to have a
discussion about what is right for the
community some people won't like it but
hey in a republic you don't always win
and that means some people will still
have to abide by an authority but not
authoritarianism which would mean my
view is oh vaccine mandates if there's a
long process if there's long-term
studies if it's been argued out in in
the in the public and we're not in a
state of panic when we do it
authoritarian position is the executor
and Sovereign shall decree the plebs do
as they're told man you keep using this
word sovereign the people are The
Sovereign that's the point I know it
just just when you say it you're
triggered if you're triggering me each
time because the people are The
Sovereign now I understand that in cases
of Emergency the executive needs to act
in a way that um would solve time
problems around the legislature
convening to debate and to legislate
right okay and that and that concept is
born of the fact that when John Adams
had to go to the Constitutional
Convention or whatever he had to ride a
horse it took him you know freaking four
weeks to get there but today yo okay
Thomas Massey will explain this very
well that the legislators could be in DC
in a matter of hours it's been 18 months
or Zoom right there's been it's been 18
months and they have not convened a
session to my knowledge on the floor of
Congress to be like hey all what should
we do about this Corona thing maybe they
should what do you mean maybe they
should you just do it GD they should do
it
I'm sorry people the absence of your
legislatures legislating and debating on
these things that impact your day-to-day
life is a sign you're living under
tyrannical rule it's tyranny
and then they're smiling while they do
it and they're like why won't you lick
it you know what you want to know what
it is you ever see this video where the
guys in a mall he's in a supermarket
tonight and he's got a mask and there's
a woman filming and he's stalking her
around yelling at her for not wearing a
mask and he goes is anybody else mad
that we have to wear masks and she
doesn't oh right let's get her and that
explains a lot of it yeah not all of it
but a lot of it there are people who are
like well if if I don't you know uh help
the the authoritarians then they'll come
after me so I have to do it then when
they get mad they have to do it and see
someone else who's not doing it they get
angry right they're like well I have to
do it you do too
you know it's weird I've been flying
quite a bit I was just in Chicago for
Jack brunch Jack brunch.com we're going
to New York next weekend come check us
out and uh I don't wear my mask at all
on the airport the only time I wear it
is when I go through security and then
as I'm gonna get to the gate when I go
on the plane and you know how many I've
been to Miami I've been to uh Las Vegas
I have been all over and do you know how
many times anybody's ever said anything
to me absolutely zero
it seems like nobody in the airport
really cares until you actually get on
the plane
and on the last flight I was on the the
captain came out and instead of the
flight attendant making the uh the
little spiel the fight the captain comes
out and he's like look I'm supposed to
say this real long thing but I'm just
going to tell you the way I see it and
he goes we have to do this and if you
turn my flight attendants into the mask
police I'm going to throw you I'm going
to send you to the cops he's like it
basically he was saying it all sucks
please don't make my flight attendants
who are just trying to earn a living
turn into some sort of masked Nazis like
he didn't say I had to ask my wife
afterwards I go did he say mask Nazis
because because that was the vibe that
he was putting out right the captain
when have you ever seen the captain get
out of the cockpit come into the
corridor and make an announcement
pre-flight I fly a lot so you don't fly
anywhere dude no I used I used to fly
twice a week okay right but but not
premium Platinum top tier I've seen the
captains come out yeah totally and I'm
sitting up front as well too but it
struck me not for something like that
because I've been it's the flight
attendants reading a thing but like
nobody in the airport wants to enforce
it nobody wants to nobody wants to
enforce these things and back in March
of 2020 when the first month I think
you're wrong that's possible they do
want to enforce it I haven't I haven't
seen it felt it or anything I think they
want it to be enforced but no one really
wants to yes they do they do want to win
who's they I mean the guy who came out
and literally said I'm enforcing this
right now but Jack was just saying he
didn't he seemed like he didn't want to
be seemed to me he was defending his
flight attendants which is the prop
which is the problem that I have with
all this is that all these mandates have
deputized normal Ordinary People into
becoming the police and these people
want to do it yeah let me explain
something so uh a story you may have
heard me tell when I had a friend say I
wish I could do what you do I want to
travel the world and I say okay buy your
plane ticket and go travel the world and
they were like well I don't have the
money for it what do you mean you got
this fancy apartment in Brooklyn like oh
well I mean you know I don't want to
lose my apartment I'm like because you
don't the the you want the apartment
more than you want to travel so when
someone says I want to do something but
they won't do it they don't want to do
it when someone says I don't want to
have to do it and they literally do it
yes something made them want to do it
defending his staff that's what that's
what I felt like his motivation was and
I can appreciate it but I can appreciate
that I can appreciate not just like I
don't want to be bullied into taking the
vaccine I don't want to be bullied into
bullying my own staff to do things what
would happen if he didn't do anything
he would be cited and fined by hotels by
the TSA how would the TSA even know what
happened somebody would report him and
then he'd be like you know we didn't
even know he was doing it we yelled at
him he wouldn't listen yeah I'm not so
sure about that well how about this he
just says I don't care
I'm not so sure about any of that but
look I've noticed the enforcement is in
very is variable too I had one guy be
like you must put your mask up in
between bites and sips and he said it
like five times in between bites and
sips and then on this other flight they
just don't care so it's it's individual
in some ways but I hear what you're
saying about collectively speaking no as
an individual that man wanted to enforce
it on you I think you could have so
let's have conflicting wants like I want
to eat a sugary cake but I also want to
be healthy so I don't eat the sugary
cake this guy I'm breaking it down very
very simply had a choice
enforce mask policy or don't now just
because his motivation for doing so was
external coercive pressures does not
mean he he didn't want to do it
he wanted to more than anything else
you're highlighting the major issue here
which is that the government is putting
us all over the fire
they're saying basically if you want to
drill all the way down what you're
saying there what you're saying is that
guy wants to feed his kids
and the risk is is he's like look I can
feed my kids or I can come out on the
mic and be like please put put your
masks on I think that if and that's a
terrible horrible crappy thing to do to
a guy a private citizen a guy just
working I hate the fact that he's been
deputized to enforce this nonsense by
threat of not of starvation of his
children but but see that that what are
you going to do if someone said I'm
sorry someone said to you basically do
this or your kids are gonna starve Tim
where are your morals troubles in my day
so that my children will know peace
Thomas Paine said that in common sense
anybody who's willing to sacrifice the
future of their children doesn't
actually care about them
look I get it they say Tim you don't
have kids you don't understand I'm like
okay fine whatever I'll just tell you
this I tried quitting Fusion you know
when I worked there and they were doing
well garbage I went to the president's
head caught my contract I don't want to
be a part of this and he said well you
know we'll come back we'll talk about it
so I couldn't do anything and I can
respect that like I did not agree to
enter a woke company and do woke garbage
and then once they started doing that I
said I won't do it and so I didn't do it
and they basically just had me in golden
handcuffs if if I was a pilot and they
said do this I'd say no
fantastic
but it's not fantastic for people that's
the problem no I understand I understand
this I understand this black and white
like Division I I get it I totally get
it and I'm in a luxury position uh where
I can make that same statement
uh most people are not most people are
not and in fact in fact my luxury is
running out because the Mandate now is
going to be
that all Varsity athletes in high school
have to get a vaccine in Montgomery
County Maryland where my kids go to
school my son is is a high school
baseball player my daughter is a high
school high school rower
and if they want to continue on in the
sport that they love playing for the
school that they like and that they go
to they're going to have to get the
vaccine what am I going to what do I do
then Tim
I tell my kids forget baseball or get
crew yes
man I wish I wish I wish I love the
system more no no then tell your kids
not to play baseball what
dude that's like telling you not to wear
a beanie and not to do this show no it
isn't yes it is exactly that no one's
mandating I get vaccinated to this show
but if somebody put a gun to your head
and said look you're gonna die or you
have to take off your [ __ ] beanie
excuse me I take it off if if that's the
Fate that's that's the same thing for a
kid in high school who wants to play
Varsity Sports whose whole life as a kid
has been like I want to play varsity
baseball is not real life baseball is
not survival baseball is something
sure adults and it is a path to success
it is a path to scholarships and you
care more about that than your kids no I
care about my kids because those things
are valuable you care more about the
fact that could play baseball than the
health and choices of your kids and
their freedom
I went to a skate park and they said you
can't come to skate park unless you're
vaccinated I bet I am going to skate
park I know but I will go into a cur a
parking lot go to another parking lot
there's no other place to pay Varsity
Sports then stop playing you see this is
it if you give people something they
will have something to lose and you will
own them that's from the villain in fast
few Fast and Furious so your solution is
to never have anything valuable to you
no that's that's a Kathy Newman well get
out of here that's an inside joke and
that's a major insult you ready to go I
didn't I didn't say you could never have
anything valuable I'm saying when your
family's being coerced you stand up and
say no
and you're what you're saying is Well
they're going to make my kids do it and
the system in place that they control
and the things they've given me are more
important than my sovereignty so be it
you you can choose to live you can you
can buy a farm you can choose to work
hard and be and and be not that simple
man you know what I wish I had that
Simplicity if it were up to me they'd be
homeschooled and playing private club
ball all the time but guess what I've
been divorced for 12 years I don't have
sovereignty over that particular issue I
can't just pick my kids up and move them
across the country right I don't have
sovereignty yes so what are so what am I
supposed to do your issue is that the
decision over your kids in the school
they go to isn't yours correct it's the
states due to a conflict with uh that's
life yes so the whole system has got me
down man and so what am I supposed to do
is my Line in the Sand gonna be taking
away from my children the thing that
they love the most you know how the hell
well I don't you want to say 14 or 16.
if it was me yeah I'll do in two seconds
you would tell your you would tell your
kid that you have been coaching in
baseball your whole life that you've
taught how to throw how to pitch how to
bat and you've talked your whole life in
about them being on a Varsity Sport and
going into college play division one
baseball and you would look them in the
eye and be like just throw that away
because Daddy's got a political position
you think your kids being forced to
undergo a medical treatment is a
political position
the statistics show very clearly that if
you take the vaccine you're pretty much
gonna be fine the statistics also show
if you don't take the vaccine you're
pretty much going to be fine so I know
that this is nothing but bullying it's
nothing but bullying and they have found
that open wound that open nerve that one
thing that I can't fight which is the
happiness and success and fulfillment
that my children feel they won
they've won I know this yeah so what am
I supposed to do about that tell your
kids stop playing baseball dude
just wait till you look at your own 16
year old yeah I'd be like Daddy's got a
political point to make so you have to
be miserable no that's that's an
oversimplification no it's not it's fair
to say I don't have kids so so perhaps I
don't share you know understand the
emotion you're feeling but uh let there
be troubles in my day so that my
children will know peace it's not a
political position to defend freedom and
stand up against tyranny that is a
responsibility especially for an
American but if the vacation won
baseball and being a a successful
baseball player is more important than
choose that and just say so simplifying
it man sometimes men and boy boys and
men need a vocation in order to become a
mature adult
and right now for my son in particular
being a baseball player is how he's
learning responsibility how he's
learning discipline how he's building
his body how he's learning about
nutrition how he's learning about risk
taking how he's learning about courage
strength loyalty being a good teammate
all those things are more important
they're more important than personal
freedom and sovereignty when I don't
have a choice you do have a choice you
just don't want to admit it you don't
want to admit it bro actually actually
at the end of the day I'm not gonna have
a choice you know why why because if I
take this all the way down to the final
Road she's going to go to court she's
going to get a court order the Court's
going to bring in their physician the
pediatrician is going to say that that
the kids should get the vaccine and the
judge is going to order it and that's
going to be that and you'll have stood
your ground
well I have stood my ground so far and I
do anticipate staying in my ground as
long as I can as far as possibly long as
I can until the absolute last drop dead
point where I have to like rip the
dreams out of my kids brains and hearts
and crush them and make them cry in
front of me
that is that is that is as far as I'm
willing to go and how many conversations
I can't tell you how many conversations
I've had with people who are like I want
to travel the world and produce
documentaries and work for these
companies and I say well then you've got
to make sacrifices and they say no the
state should give me the money no they
shouldn't how about you get rid of your
apartment do you like so much but I've
worked so hard to finally get my own
place to have my own place to call my
home I deserve this and if I want to be
a journalist and travel and travel the
world and do these do this do these
things I shouldn't have to sacrifice
having a place to live yeah that's some
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] that's nothing that's
nothing that's this is this is life
that's nothing that's nothing that is
that is making decisions between I want
to drink beer or I want to drink water I
want to work at this or I want to do
that that is somebody's Choice okay
we're talking about government compelled
vaccines and medical services
and I do and I will fight it as far as I
possibly can but what I'm doing is I'm
acknowledging that that I will do
nothing but fight and it will all be in
vain because I know the entire system is
built against me I am fighting Tim I'm
fighting every single day and I'm going
to fight you know who I'm talking to
right now if you're watching I'm gonna
fight all the way to the end okay you
know who I'm talking to I'm gonna fight
all the way to the end the point I'm
making is that I I do not accept people
coming to me using words to to to to to
uh State how they feel about something
and then immediately doing the opposite
proving everything they said was
[ __ ]
when someone says I just wish I had
chocolate cake and I'm like there's all
the ingredients in front of you I'm not
gonna make it so you don't really wish
you had it dude I'm not willing to do
what you need to do that's what I
understand that I totally understand it
if the vaccine had a 20 rate of
paralyzing kids obviously this choice
would be much more clear
right this negative side effects of the
vaccine are almost the same as the
negative side effects to get in Corona
it's they're very close we're talking
about 99.9 percentage or 99.9 of that
did you see the study that said that
there's a higher risk of myocarditis
than yes I I read that of course I have
a history of pericarditis I have a
history of heart inflammation I am a
completely zeroed in on this issue in
particular that study was pre-print it
was look I tweeted that study I was like
yes to this study it was pre-print it
was not peer-reviewed it was only on 120
day hospitalization rate and it didn't
it had some stale data okay it wasn't
perfect people been tweeting out like
it's been perfect but it wasn't a lot of
it a lot of the stuff people have been
tweeting out to counter the vaccine
mandates are like
imperfect it's all in perfect and this
is why I want more time the rate of
change in the data is still so great but
let's let's slow down this is not about
the vaccine I don't know this is it's
about being compelled by the government
to do things that you don't want to do
exactly
and so the issue is the the issue the
issue is do I want to make my political
point for the uh on the blood of my
children or do I have an alternative
route where I can make a political point
that has more impact with less negative
side and less negative side effects and
maybe I'm [ __ ] cucking out excuse me
maybe I'm being a b-i-tch in this matter
you just said the f word I know I'm
sorry dude but but like my point is it's
like
sometimes the cost benefit analysis when
it comes down to it when it's your kids
hopes and dreams and for me I have
alternative Avenues right like I have a
show I have an audience I have influence
I can make things happen I haven't I
have a way to impact the world that
doesn't revolve around me sacrificing my
kids
well how are you sacrificing your kids
by if if I if I refused them ultimately
at the end of the day if they were if
the only choice they had was vaccine or
Athletics and I said no Athletics to
them that would be sacrificing them but
there's other ways to engage in
athletics
uh one one would one can yes if you move
to Florida if you move to West Virginia
if you moved to Texas but again I'm
hamstrung I'm screwed
it's how they win what do they want to
do what do the kids want to do they want
they want to play Varsity Sports and
they don't want to be bothered by this
okay how do your kids feel about getting
vaccinated my son you know he's as based
as it comes so he's kind of like I don't
know maybe I should maybe I shouldn't my
daughter's like I don't care I just
don't want to be hassled yeah
this is how because they're not informed
they don't really know so this this this
is why I quoted The Fast and the Furious
villain when he said give the people
something to lose and you own them
imagine what life would have been like
for you and your family 300 years ago
you wouldn't be having this conversation
you'd be like if my kids are going to
eat they're gonna go break their backs
in the fields all day with me yeah now
you're like my son needs to play
baseball
don't mock it like that no I'm not
trying to mock it but let's put it there
are very few places in this world today
where a young man can learn virtue okay
competitive Sports is a place where you
can learn virtue
courage honor loyalty how about an MMA
gym
vax mandate in DC bro
what what am I supposed to do they're
boxing me in in every which way possible
well without leaving the uh learning
virtues practicing virtues there's is a
political statement and of it to itself
there's three states out within like an
hour of DC I mean actually Virginia and
Maryland are with like literally in DC
basically you just two minutes some some
you can live in DC and like across the
street and be in in Maryland or Virginia
indeed and then it's an hour to West
Virginia where they don't have these
things and you could go to like a gym or
whatever the point is man what I'm
saying is
yeah it sucks but if someone tells me
like these things are wrong however
baseball's more important I'm like just
say it
no character development
yes all of those things
through baseball that your son learns
are more important than like standing up
to you talking about building for the
future building a child that is virtuous
is courageous is Honorable is loyal is
loyal
is perhaps more important for the long
term than making a political stand in a
in a losing battle today it is a
tactical retreat
so that you can be stronger and better
for the future yeah but if we go this
route there's not going to be a stronger
a better future it's going to be
continued capitulation by more and more
people who refuse to make a stand look
I'm getting texts at the comments are
calling me blue pill and teaching
submission and stuff like that fine I'm
sure people are telling me I don't have
you guys a few guys okay wait until
you're in my exact particular position
and you have to make these calculated
decisions this is why they're doing it
they're doing it to act make us go
through Agony yep life Agony
I told you the story about the wolf and
the family I read story told a lot
because it really made me think there
was I read this article about a uh a
family was on a beach and it was bought
there by themselves when a black wolf
started walking down and the father saw
it and panicked and then all the kids it
was like three kids the mom and the dad
and they they swam out to a rock that
was like you know 20 or 20 to 50 feet
off of the shore and they were huddled
together on this rock shivering as the
wolf paced back and forth fourth
terrified begging for help and praying
that someone would save them and I'm
like man I wonder what would have
happened if this was 300 years ago
I mean what would the father have even
brought his wife and daughters with him
in the first place if he did because
they were going to the beach because
humans like to go to the beach maybe
they'd be working and fishing and the
Wolf showed up what would the the dad
would have done I don't know drawn a
single shot Flintlock and his sword and
said stand back family wearing like
Leathers of some sort or would he have
you know coward as well I don't know
maybe it's romanticized in the past to
assume that the father would have been
like take the kids and run and then drew
his sword and stared down the wolf and
said you know and if the wolf charged
him he would have fought to the death to
save his family in the Modern Age you
know I was thinking about this how like
we walk around with literal thin like
less than a millimeter thin cloth you
know back in the day people many of them
would carry weapons and wear hide or
Furs or Leathers things substantially
thicker to protect themselves from the
elements were so safe and coddled we
snap our fingers we get food we go
outside we wear shorts flip-flops
totally a soft-bellied and and
unprepared and more and more people in
these cities are giving up their rights
to self-defense and the right to keep in
bear arms and I'm not saying I'm not
passing a moral judgment I'm just saying
I wonder I wonder how different things
would have would have been I wonder what
our ancestors would say about us today
when they would hear these stories you
know and it's like I gotta make a
decision between having my apartment or
having my my accomplishing my goals or I
have to make a decision between owning
this refrigerator that's got a tablet in
it or the dishwasher that's gonna do the
extra scrub cycle and I'm like are these
the problems that you know it's it's you
know I've been thinking I've been
feeling more and more that's we're in
behavioral sync when the problems of our
day is that the the government is is it
has be has gone from a republic of
elected officials gathering together to
legislate on our behalf for the most
part and our uh hearings and our
discussions and journalism challenging
these things it's gone from that to an
executive ruling by decree and people
now are saying
but dude I love those chicken wings you
know so if they mandate it I'm just
gonna say fine I you know I know I'm
opposed to the mandates but I really
want to perform at this club and it's
going to make money for me so I'll just
do it
there are a lot of people right now that
I'm not going to shout anybody out
because there are some people have
tremendous respect who have been hitting
me up saying that when the Mandate
started passing the cities they started
canceling their shows Jim Brewer did it
some other comedians Christopher did who
did Christy mayor yeah she did yeah oh
well yeah yeah yeah and there you go
look guys sacrificing income let me just
make things perfectly clear especially
to you know who if you're watching I'm
going to fight this until a judge orders
me otherwise okay but for the sake of
argument I'm expressing all my emotions
and my feelings about this matter I am
agonizing over this this is existential
okay it's historic this is about our
country our values it's about everything
that we're doing here in our society and
I'm fighting it and it sucks and it
hurts and it's hurting me it hurts you
ever hear the story of uh it was one of
the signers of the Declaration of
Independence his wife was captured and
used as a prisoner of war in exchange
there's this viral mean that goes around
about everything that was lost by the
the signers and it's exaggerated I
actually went through the list and I
sought to fact check a lot of this stuff
because I wanted to make sure I was
accurate when I was talking about the
sacrifices made by those who signed the
Declaration of Independence
um I think only one guy was killed
some were imprisoned briefly most uh not
most but a handful lost their homes to
British occupation one guy had his wife
they went to his house ransacked it took
his wife and held her as a prisoner for
a prisoner exchange so these guys uh I
think it was John Adams who has a quote
where he said like basically
paraphrasing we're gonna lose and we're
gonna lose everything swearing on our
you know our sacred blood and honor you
know to stand by this and they thought
they would lose everything and you know
the thing is the founding fathers didn't
just put up their names and their
treasure and their homes they put their
children on the line and their wives on
the line but this is this is something
that I have thought about extensively
which is the conditions for winning are
not present okay I am not going to be
the one it Gallipoli that jumps out of
the trench and runs into a Machine Gun
Nest just because the generals haven't
figured out a way to create the
conditions for victory in 1770s the
conditions for victory were there
obviously
the risk that they took the risk that
they took wasn't in vain obviously
okay the conditions for Recovery exist
they do not they they do currently at
this moment in time yes but okay then
why aren't you down at the White House
throwing a coup what what how is that a
condition for Victor how are you going
to win what are you going to win right
now Tim tell me what are you going to do
for the one thing we we just filed for
two different non-profits one is a fact
checking it's not winning dude that's
fighting I'm talking about the
conditions winning the conditions for
winning require you engage in the
conflict engaging is different and so I
will not I will not murder my children
at a hopeless cause grabbing a semantic
problem you're arguing that there's
literally nothing you could do right now
to flick a switch and it would all be
over correct we need to make we need to
change the conditions such that a martyr
type activity could lead to a victory we
do not have the conditions Martyrs right
now would just be jumping off a cliff
that's it no gain so no game what's to
be gained by keeping your kid in
baseball
creating a virtuous man that his cow
talent and opportunity there's no other
way to do that there are other ways to
do that there are other ways to do that
yeah that's true why not choose those I
won't have a choice Court a judge is
going to order me sure sure so you can
stand up and get I will stand up and I
will get to that point and I will get to
that point and and if it were me I'd say
thank you your honor have a nice day and
I'd walk out you know Pat my son in the
head and say all right you know that
this is this is the way thing goes we'll
we'll keep pushing through because
sometimes you don't you don't win every
battle but you you don't lose your head
over it so I would say you don't gotta
like if it were me I wouldn't be angry I
wouldn't be I mean I'd be like be angry
but not in the sense where it's like
you're energized by it to the point
where you're you're yelling and stuff
like if it were me I'd be like we got to
be tactical we're pissed off for sure
and if we lose this battle we'll keep
pushing on if uh if it were me however
I'd say baseball's out I guess look
ultimately I think someone who's 14 I
think in this capacity you should ask
your son what he wants to do and if he
says I accept this and I will play
baseball I say all right well I mean
ultimately that's what it's going to
come down to yeah and then I I would say
okay you know you're 14 and there's
certain things I wouldn't let them
choose to do and some things I'd say you
know ultimately it comes out of this I
genuinely think the vaccines are safe I
I I I there's a lot of people who think
that there's a lot of you know crazy
adverse reactions we talked about the
Nicki Minaj stuff and I'm like I
honestly think these kids are going to
be fine
um I think the reason we see such high
fares reporting is because such of high
vaccine rate of vaccination it is as you
stated a political conundrum where the
executive is taking over and we're
trying to push back against it right so
you've correctly addressed the calculus
here which is this is not I'm not going
to uh ultimately give in to tyrannical
power at the expense of my children's
health
okay if it were specifically about my
children's health I would fight it
gunpoint
okay
to the end to the death
but the truth is is not necessarily
about their long-term health
right take the facts you'll be fine
don't take the vax you'll be fine this
is all about politics so the question
now is I'm going to make a political
statement versus that if it was a
political statement versus their health
and well-being that's a different story
that's the Nuance this is and again I'm
fighting this we're just having a
discussion I'm throwing this out there
to be open and honest so that other
people out there who are having these
similar feelings can relate and know
that they're not alone and that we can
talk and share about the the barrel that
the government is putting us over in the
way that they're torturing us with this
that's why I'm talking about all this I
remember when I was on uh in the 2018
Rogan I did with Dorsey whatever
at the end of the episode you know
towards the end I said if you keep doing
what you're doing we'll get to the point
where people are going to be shooting
each other in the streets I don't know I
don't remember the exact quote I had but
I was like it's going to get crazy and
uh well this stuff started to happen but
the point I made was I'm building a van
yeah and I built a van and I have the
van and I was like and if I have to I'll
take my van down by the river yeah I
remember that video I Remember You made
a video where you're like I'm literally
getting in my van and I'm going down to
the river and that's that so the point
I'm making with that is not some people
have been like Tim's talking about
abandoning and no no no no no I'm saying
there is nothing you can take away from
me that would make me stand down you
like you would have to physically remove
me put me lock me up do whatever if it
came down to actual like civil Civil War
and like real conflict they'd have to
like drag me into you know Kicking and
Screaming into a pen or something and so
yeah yeah I hear you man
I hear you shall we talk about something
else I think we should okay let's talk
about uh this ethics violation for AOC
good conversation though yes check out
the story there's there's a twofold
story here AOC is a hypocrite and a liar
we got this from timcast.com ethics
complaint filed against AOC for
accepting free Met Gala ticket AOC wore
a tax the rich dress to the exclusive
event there's a lot of people I see who
are like why does anyone care about this
so dumb but I'll tell you this issue of
AOC has the left completely fractured
and you can really see who the true
leftists are when they call out AOC
there is a hardcore communist uh Cartoon
Avatar Twitter account that won't shut
up and hates everybody because everybody
Nazis won't stop rag on AOC for being a
limousine liberal for being a villain in
The Hunger Games and I'm like I think
these people genuinely are communists
when they say that stuff and they call
out AOC for being a capitalist corporate
shill who's going to a met gal a 35 000
event and then you get high profile
leftists who are like I think it's good
she did it you know and they're posting
this meme you know that that Meme where
the guy's like I think we should improve
Society somewhat and then the guy pops
out of the well like yeah you live in
society I'm very intelligent it's like
yo
saying that we should improve I love
that comment comic because whenever
someone posts it you know that they're
not smart
because saying something like I think
it's bad that you know people at Foxconn
labs are you know killing themselves or
have been and then that was the gist of
like the argument that you know people
on the right were like oh these leftists
are protesting this stuff but they're
using iPhones
yes when you buy the iPhone you are
quite literally voting with your dollars
for those companies to continue those
horrible conditions you are allowed to
participate in society and you have an
option you buy an Android phone you can
check into where it's made and maybe
it's got parts from Foxconn or you can
try and get a phone that's made
somewhere else
hope that it's not
so AOC is getting an active complaint
and here's the big issue here's what I
think everyone should be calling this
out
she received a gift
of thirty five thousand dollars now
I made the argument man I got allergies
I made the argument that uh it could be
considered a consideration for an
appearance come on getting that high
profile Progressive 12 million followers
they give her a free ticket that gives
them tremendous value look at the buzz
around the Met Gala people don't even
know what the Met Gala is and now they
do because they comped a ticket for AOC
and she got them press
sounds to me like the ticket was
consideration which is legal exchange of
value in which case she would owe taxes
on that and be committing uh it's an
Ethics violation it might actually be a
crime
regardless
people who are in Congress cannot
receive these kinds of gifts
do you imagine
I mean what they're doing go to uh go to
uh any politician and be like
we're having a charity event everyone
gets a free meal you can hang out
celebrities go on TV it will be great
for your re-election campaign now it
costs a hundred grand but don't worry
we're comping the gift to you
yeah dude I have a guy in the liminal
order that used to work in the Trump
Administration and during the time that
uh he was working there I kept saying to
him I'm like hey man you know join up
I'll give you a discount join up I'll
give you a discount he's like dude I
can't he's like I can't take a discount
it's a bribe it was a few hundred bucks
okay and the guy refused and the day he
got out of office he signed up okay this
is this is the level of Integrity that
I've seen from people working in Trump
Administration and then now you see AOC
taking this comp for consideration for
thirty thousand dollars without batting
an eye you got Nico a little behind you
being eaten by Joe Biden mind you that's
a g Prime 85 comic George alexopoulos is
great and Nicolo bought herself what was
like a was a million dollar apartment I
thought it was three million but no no
that's a song yeah yeah so she's the tax
the rich okay Boomer Bernie shirt
wearing girl who buys herself a million
dollar property and Hassan is the
Socialist who bought himself a three
million dollar house and uh you know my
issue with it is the first thing I'll
say is congratulations you're six you
know you've earned your success you've
inspired people I don't think people
aren't allowed to be rich and I think
that for the positions of many of these
people they don't they're not over
communist tankies like sees everyone's
wealth for the state so they they still
believe in getting rich but there is
still this level of hypocrisy where they
frequently come out in favor of
authoritarian it's not leaked I don't
know what Nico low is all about I don't
think she's even political for the most
part but like Hassan for instance
frequently comes out in the size sides a
side of authoritarianism
and then buys himself a massive property
and I'm like I'm not going to believe
you're actually a leftist if you just
say things and then do things that are
con like contradictory to your beliefs
AOC accepting a 35 000 gift and then
what does she say I wanted to show a
working class woman of color you know
bring in the the the the the the the
protest to them and I'm like dude you're
in you're there smiling and laughing and
like hanging out with these billionaires
the protest would have been I'm not
going screw you I'm out front eat tax
the rich all the rich are inside y'all
we should be taxing all of them if she
really wanted to protest she should have
been standing on the red carpet and as
everyone walked by should throw red
paint on them be like tax the rich tax
the rich tax the rich throw red paint on
them fine but you know what I'm saying
that but she could have said she could
have stood outside got a camera and said
I was invited to this event they
expected me to accept consideration of
35
000 to come to their fancy event while I
think it's fine people are allowed to
have these events I said no I won't take
your bribe text the rich and now we're
gonna be out she didn't do that she went
inside she had her meal and she had a
staff member carrying her dress for her
ethics violation 100 now is anything
going to happen to her for this probably
not she probably did like a million
Twitter followers for it or something
yeah that's right she knows this is one
of the people that knows that politics
is Downstream she she knows People
magazine is where it's at not Politico
this the country is oh you mentioned it
earlier the Republic's Gone Gone Mark
million General
he's like oh yeah I had the phone call
with China oh yeah I think that I warned
them I think that was the Millie thing
that's a different topic but I you know
but the point I'm bringing up with this
is that we're at a point where AOC can
accept basically a 35 000 bribe
okay and Mark milley can call the
Chinese military and say you now we're
in a conflict that's had been escalating
and you've been engaging in militaristic
actions that we've been telling you to
stop doing we won't attack you don't
worry about it so they're pressing on
Taiwan we send in a strike group they
they start loading up these missiles so
we we diversify our our Air Force around
the Pacific Islands and then Millie's
like it's just don't worry we're not
gonna attack you that that seems like
something you shouldn't tell your enemy
when they're when they're doing things
in violation of international law he
particularly thinks they're not the
enemy he I saw yesterday a couple years
ago where he was saying they're very
powerful they're getting stronger but
that doesn't mean there are so the point
is we can watch fauci lie to Congress
and Rand Paul can have the evidence in a
document that says the NIH funded gain
of function research nothing will happen
lies AOC lied James Clapper lied to
Congress that's right those Hillary
Clinton emails were so insane the Sydney
Blumenthal stuff in Libya so-and-san
with with
he died I mean just it was so so corrupt
but I mean the Federal Reserves so
corrupt it's so obvious but what it's so
obvious if you look at it but if you
don't look at it it's not obvious and
people they don't they look past it when
they see it they don't understand it so
they don't even see it I don't know
what's going on I gotta I gotta be
honest I don't think we lived in a
republic since 1913. no we definitely
have not these people you know they're
getting bribed like I mean it's not a
legitimate Republic there are people
there representing but they're they're
getting remember when when Lindsay
Lindsey Graham I think it was goes out
he's complaining about the election and
stuff then he goes out and he fist bumps
Kamala Harris yeah that's true too hard
it's all done well tax the rich means
confiscate private property all the
Communists believe they're going to be
the commissars they're all just stupid I
got no problem with uh a right-wing
politician walk up to a left-wing
politician and give it a fist bump I got
a problem with them Grand standing on TV
pretending like they're morally opposed
and then behind closed doors be like I
got your back I have a problem with
people claiming to be fighting for
something and they don't actually fight
for it you know what the problem is
right now Mark milley uh should be
court-martialed yes hands down Al
vindman of all people to I think he
tweeted this out I don't know where he
posted but I think it was a tweet where
he said that if this is true Mark milley
usurp civilian Authority and by Breaking
the Chain of Command
the New York Times reported on this in
January 8th with an update on the 13th
that Nancy Pelosi
look there's a few pieces of of data
missing maybe Trump told Millie we're
not going to attack China maybe he told
him that but that's not what happened
but maybe he knew that but the issue is
but the reporting is that it was a
secret call outside of chain of command
and that Mark milley convened a secret
meeting at the Pentagon instructing
senior officers to effect essentially
defy legal orders from Donald Trump
yes after a call from Nancy Pelosi now
what happened was the New York Times
reported on January 8th can we Define
something very quickly
uh look I am not a mark milley fan I am
a drop Donald Trump supporter I hate
Nancy Pelosi I'm on the gum on the right
side but I have questions
my first question is is what is the
actual exact nuclear launch protocol
what does that have to do with this
because does the president just say
launch the nukes and then some guy in a
silo turns the key or does it have to go
from the president to the Joint Chief
down the chain of command what does it
have to do with because as far as I read
the text specifically Millie said
if we're talking about a nuclear strike
it I have to be part of it or something
like that right which reinforced the
chain of command so what or or what he
thought was a chain of command what is
the actual chain of command if Trump
says launch the nukes where did what
what is the actual literal Next Step
does he give the order to the Joint
chief
and then and then the guy that turns the
key has to take the order from The Joint
Chiefs or does he have to take it from
the president
this is a very important crucial let me
let me break this stuff down for you
the hill reported the forthcoming book
says Millie conducted secret meetings at
the Pentagon after January secret from
whom to ensure former president Trump
could not launch a military attack
secret from the public secret from Trump
from Trump
to ensure that Trump could not launch
this in military attack so so specific
look I'm a trump guy I'm not a milli guy
I just want to have the facts so we can
argue the right things
and so he specifically said if Donald
Trump says attack
you come to me
look me in the eyes right now and swear
enough you will come to me
with this
but but but
to an officer and then he says no you
come to me instead I I'm not in the
military I have no idea how this works
is an enlisted guy supposed to take an
order directly from the president or
does the list of guy have to take an
order from him you got to stop
okay before you jumped in okay the New
York Times reported that when Pelosi
contacted mark milley saying she was
concerned about Donald Trump launching a
military strike that it seems Mark
milley offered no uh consideration to
this request
and the Department of Defense several
Department of Defense officials were
angered by this saying that if they
actually did plan on circumventing the
chain of command it would be a military
coup
vindman said if this report is correct
he that Millie usurped civilian
Authority Breaking the Chain of Command
I am not saying it is my opinion this
happened I'm saying New York Times
reported DOD officials said if they
sought to break the chain of command it
would be a military coup
command but we haven't defined what the
chain of command is the Enderman said it
was but vinman said that the president
can give an enlisted guy an order that
all of the commanding officers disagree
with and the enlisted guy has to do it I
don't jack I I think your questions are
completely irrelevant I think that
you're supposed to only answer to your
uh uh immediate officer your immediate
Superior and then if another greater
Spirit comes over and tells you
something you're like sorry none of this
is relevant to my that's what um none of
this relevant relevant to my point my
point was that according to the New York
Times when they initially reported this
they said Pelosi tried to make it happen
it didn't happen
and so I report that as
Pelosi attempts military coup against
Trump and I said I'm not going to mince
words if the New York Times reporting
Department of Defense officials said
what Nancy Pelosi attempted to get them
to do would have been a military coup
that's what I'm going to say happened a
lot of people on the left were angry by
it no that didn't happen she was just
trying to stop a crazy man from starting
a a war and I'm like I don't care the
New York Times reported this I'm not
going to give my opinion I'm going to
stay with the New York Times reported
venderman says that this report uh and
you don't have to trust finman I'm just
making the point that you have many
people coming out right now even people
on the left saying this broke the chain
of command
he gave he gave information to an
adversary without conferring with the
president
that seems like a big problem to me
treason no we're not declared enemies of
China we actually have you know a ton of
agreements with them we're not at War
although we literally are at War we're
not well they're they're at war with us
we're at war with them we are well
they're they're at war with us they're
engaging they're Waging War on us and
and not technically the point is we we
didn't declare war against them so it's
just uh an off the books conflict I
guess you can call it but they've been
attacking our critical infrastructure
for a long long time so anyway the point
is
Millie according to the reports held a
secret had a secret phone call with
Chinese military
telling them outright
all of our posturing
all of our our our ships going through
China We're Not Gonna attack you that's
actually makes me think that we have way
better ties with the Chinese government
than it seems that we're really safe and
there's not going to be any physical
conflict
China recently had a strike group go
into the Alaskan economic zone and look
when China says we will or right up next
to the economics when China says we will
take Taiwan
when China is actively sinking fishing
boats in the South China Sea claiming
control over it when they're illegally
building military bases on the atolls
and the U.S can only saber Rattle and
then the best we have is saber rattling
Mark Melly in October before the
election even happened calls them and
says don't worry we're not gonna attack
you
and if we are going to I will give you
advanced warning is this not and again
I'm not a milli fan I'm a trump
supporter I believe China's Waging War
on us Etc I just want to know the facts
okay if we're conducting a military
exercise do we not notify our
adversaries in advance that we're
conducting a military exercise wait wait
wait are you asking that if we're going
to fire a missile on our enemy not to
declare war we would warn them first and
exercise but that's not what we're
talking about he said so you need to
understand what's been going on all last
year China has been actively pushing on
the Pacific in many ways that are
considered illegal sinking fishing boats
for instance has been a huge red flag
for the US and their allies so the U.S
deploys destroyers into the South China
Sea challenging China's claims over the
territory China is trying to put enough
pressure on the U.S to get us to back
down so they can eventually declare
sovereignty over the area one of the
things stopping them was that China was
scared if they kept pressing the U.S
would attack so Mark milley's is
reported in in the full report from The
Washington Post in the book they
specifically State because China was
concerned that the U.S would be prepared
to attack them Mark milley called them
in October of 2020 to warn them not to
worry we will not attack you everything
is fine and in the event we will launch
an attack I will call you and warn you
first that was him pledging to an
adversary in the event War were to break
out he would side with them he would
give them warning of our military plans
yes and by stating that we will not
attack you he completely undermined
everything the U.S had been doing in the
Pacific to stop China's encroachment in
the Pacific when China was scared we
were going to attack that I'm not saying
war is good no it's bad but if China was
like Hey the US might attack us you
think that's a deterrent right so he
undermined that completely going outside
of the chain of command to do so
secretly secretly contacting the Chinese
military to inform them and is and he
said as you mentioned in the past when
he said that China is not our enemy
China's been conducting cyber warfare
against us forever they're very clearly
Waging War on us there's no question
about it I'll tell you my my number my
number one source and look again I'm
just trying to figure out what the facts
are right here and I'm not an expert
look I know a lot of stuff about a lot
of things but I do not I'm not an expert
on Chinese incursions into the South
China Sea okay I can admit that uh the
the source of my skepticism
is the fact that this was reported in a
bob Woodward book okay and just if it
really confirmed it fine
but if it came out last year and it was
about Trump and it was about Bob
Woodward everyone on our side or on my
side at least would be like that Bob
Woodward is an idiot and a liar that's
that that's yes but he confirmed it fair
enough yeah he said it was it was it was
he said it was acceptable and routine
and we regularly so maybe maybe it is
acceptable and routine then why so so
the issue I suppose then is when you've
done something that's so shocking once
again you see everyone on the right
saying this is shocking if true that
even people on the left are coming out
like that's why I cited vendeman
specifically yeah I'm not trying to
claim that he's an expert and Authority
on this I'm saying he's the guy who
tried to get Trump impeached or who did
get Trump impeached yeah now coming out
and being like this broke the chain of
command but aren't there also other
incidences where like we've attacked
people and I think I think this is
pretty common we're like we're gonna
launch a missile on this on this base
like with Trump in Syria you should move
you should move some people out of there
we don't want to kill a bunch of people
we just want to blow up a bunch of
equipment we're launching this missile
missile's coming
I mean notifying our adversaries in
advance of a military attack is not
unprecedented not in the age of limited
War I think the issue is that he went
around Donald Trump okay that's fine
again let me read something for you I
can feel the comments this is New York
Times
New York Times January 8th with an
update on January 13th they mentioned
speaker Pelosi of California took the
unprecedented step of asking the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
about available precautions to prevent
Trump from initiating military action
abroad or using his sole authority to
launch nuclear weapons in the last days
of his term so apparently has sole
authority to launch nuclear weapons I
guess General melee has appears to have
made no commitments that's what they
said in January we now know that he did
in fact had a secret meeting at the
Pentagon where he he according to the
book and again you don't got to believe
Woodward he asked these officers to
effectively swear an oath to him that if
Trump gave him an order they'd go to him
with it first okay that's that's the
question I want to know
that's the question I want to know so
let me read does the president can the
president I understand the question let
me read Millie made no commitments Mrs
Pelosi's request which she announced in
the Democratic caucus is an effort to
prevent an unhinged president from using
the nuclear codes was wrapped in the
politics of seeking a second impeachment
of trump Colonel David Butler spokesman
for General Millie confirmed the phone
call the speaker had taken place but
described it as informational he
answered her questions regarding the
process of nuclear command Authority but
some defense Department officials
clearly resented being asked to act
outside of the legal authority of the
25th Amendment and saw it as more
evidence of a broken political system
they said that some political leaders
were trying to get the Pentagon to do
the work of Congress and cabinet
secretaries who have legal options to
remove a president Mr Trump they noted
is still the commander-in-chief unless
he is removed the military is bound to
follow his lawful orders while military
officials can refuse to carry out orders
they view as illegal or slow the process
by sending those orders for careful
legal review they cannot remove the
president from the chain of command that
would amount to a military coup the
official said
okay that being said if vendman is
correct in saying that this broke chain
of command if there was there was
another retired retired Colonel on Fox
News who said outright this was an
illegal action by Millie of true he
should be brought into Congress put
under oath and testifies to what
happened
we have people left right military
coming out and saying this was a
subversive action against the United
States treason we're not at war with
China
um formally in which case I don't think
it counts as treason uh
court-martialable I'm not in the
military I wouldn't know if it goes
against the um
the the military code or anything like
that but I certainly think that Mark
milley has acted Beyond reproach the
secret meeting at the Pentagon now this
one's not confirmed what is confirmed is
that Millie is admitted to this me this
phone call with China on more than one
occasion on in October and in Jan on
January 8th
the claim from the left in the
mainstream media is that he was just
trying to stop an unhinged president who
he had seen who he believed was in
mental decline following an Insurrection
attempt except he made the first call in
October according to the reporting well
before an election took place so imagine
Donald Trump who's been very very
bullish on you know going up against
China
imagine he won the election he had
already been undermined by The Joint the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs who went or
who went behind his back to contact
China
and that's admitted I said it's routine
you know I talked to the militaries of
all these other countries all the time
but there's a lot of people in the
military who said not true okay so
here's why I see it fine maybe it's not
uh treason maybe it's not Court martial
how about we the people who are
requesting an investigation and and
inquiry into this one get it and we we
get to the bottom of it and then we
determine whether or not he brought
senior officers into the Pentagon to
tell them that if Trump gives you an
order you bring it to me
we still in that article didn't get a
clear delineation of what the nuclear
command structure is well I I suppose
they pointed out its sole authority of
the president but what is the chain of
command does the president go to the key
Turner directly or does it have to go
down the line that's important
distinction you know well so let's put
this we've spent so much time parsing
text when it came to Trump and watching
the left take things that Trump said
that were specifically accurate but then
expanding it into being generally
inaccurate and I just don't want us to
do that like I just want us to be
specific and so that's right and
justified in our critiques so the
ultimate question is can Donald Trump
get on the phone to they don't use NORAD
anymore I guess but can you get on the
phone to a commander to military base
with nuclear capabilities and say let's
watch the nukes yeah I believe the
answer is yes I believe the answer is no
you don't think my instinct is I don't I
have no other basis Trump is the one
with the nuclear football who else will
be able to do it yeah I don't know it
seems to me the uh in something that
could end the world that we would want
it to go down the chain of command from
one officer to the community I think the
Democrats tried to make that happen
actually they tried to take Biden's Soul
Authority for the nuclear launch codes
away and give it to somebody give it to
more than just him I think it's him no I
understand the question is down the
chain of command
I I would be surprised if Trump could
not call you know Strategic Defense you
know a commander or Captain a major a
general or whatever who has the ability
to turn the key and say this is
President Donald Trump calling on the
red phone
he could you know I'm sure you have to
call it General I suppose but he doesn't
have to call Millie right yeah so if
Millie as the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs now here's the important part as
chairman of the Joint Chiefs he's not
active in the military he's an advisor
he's a so it's it's called it's semantic
but my understanding based on the
reporting is that as the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs he acts as the senior
military advisor to the president and
doesn't make the decisions himself which
means Trump would not go to him to
execute the decisions gotcha he would go
to the senior officers the generals and
say
do it for him to come out and be like no
you come to me instead
I don't know man uh calling China at a
time when we're facing thucydides trap
sounds to me like providing Aid to the
enemy yeah we're not worthy on that
we're not doing that how about we go to
super chats let's do it maybe maybe
there'll be a general in the super chats
you can explain yeah oh yeah and so we
got a ton of super chats because we said
we all we all said so many things that
we weren't clear on and people are going
to provide for us those uh
clarifications so here Google says the
United States has a two-man rule in
place at nuclear launch facilities and
while only the president can order the
release of nuclear weapons the order
must be verified
by the Secretary of Defense to be an
authentic order given by the president
there is an hierarchy etc etc and it's
not marketing it's not Mark Miller yeah
so he has to be a secret meeting it has
to be verified by the SEC deaf and it
not have to be verified by The Joint
Chiefs according to a preliminary Google
search so that's a military coup if
that's true yeah that's whack it's whack
and and look my instinct is to say yes
Millie and Pelosi uh coup treason but I
want us to be very specific in what
we're saying and I'm not going to take
anything to Bob Woodward says at face
value yeah I agree
um it's it's not treason
yeah
well no no like if if this meeting
happened assuming it is the reporting is
correct it would just be I think
sedition
you know against the government oh wait
a command signal or watch alert would
then be issued to the Joint Chiefs of
Staff oh okay the president would then
review the attack options with the
secretary of defense and the chairman of
the joy Chiefs of Staff and decide on a
plan which could range from a single
cruise missile to multiple ICBM launches
all right so there it is if the
president who is the commander-in-chief
or decides to order the use of nuclear
weapons they would be taken aside by the
carrier and the briefcase would be
opened a command signal or watch alert
would then be issued to the Joint Chiefs
now here's the other question okay so
clearly if you read the text
very explicitly Millie says basically I
want you guys to just make sure that you
include me in this and that appears to
be the exact process considering we know
that he went to uh one of our greatest
adversaries and provided them with key
insights into our military plans no
doubt do you believe his spokesman when
his spokesman says don't worry it was
just informational and it was just to
confirm the um that the process the
legal process for launching a military
action now here's the other question I
mean no no hold on that's what I felt
like when I read Trump wants to launch a
military strike does he need Mark milley
yes it says that's a nuclear strike the
president would re oh a nuclear strike
if Donald Trump wanted to send Commandos
into Yemen would he need Mark Milly's
approval I don't think so so that's the
issue is that the New York Times said it
was about military action or nuclear a
strike gotcha well as soon as I heard
the story it struck me as being
reasonable that the joint Chief of Staff
would have to be involved in nuclear
strike decision
and so I think the nuclear thing is the
red herring yeah it is it's the
conventional War because if Millie's not
supposed to be involved in a
conventional War uh command from Trump
then it's it's and he's telling them to
give him that information then that's
outside the box how do you convince
people on the left that uh they say
Trump's mentally declining Insurrection
and we can't let him use nukes when the
actual core of of all the articles is
that stopping from Trump from military
action we wouldn't nuke China we'd send
in a destroyer and fire some cruise
missiles or something non you know
non-uh nuclear or whatever yeah so maybe
um I don't know I know that Trump uh
signed off on a bunch of crazy raids and
stuff and you know civilians died and
all that stuff drone strikes things like
that I don't know if he has to get
approval from The Joint Chiefs to do it
I guess my main point in general is not
to have amnesia about people that we
don't trust say one they say one thing
we're like oh we don't trust you you're
an idiot and then they say something
that we like we're like oh you're
absolutely right that's what I I'm
looking just for a little bit more rigor
yeah okay that's all that the whole
point in this exercise is about rigor so
that we can be right and we can be
prepared and we can defend our positions
so uh one Super Chat that just came in
uh I'll read I'll read two I'll go to
the beginning but I'll read these two
just for the sake of what we're here
bass player says the president does have
sole authorization to release nuclear
weapons upon the order for launch
the uh the upon the order for launch the
orders and codes are sent to the launch
sites officers on duty authenticate the
codes and if they are authentic they
fire ghost of Recon says the Joint
Chiefs have no decision Authority they
are not in the chain of command oh
that's not that's not what no no no it
does it doesn't say that he's not
involved he's saying he's not in the
chain of command so the issue then is we
need an under oath inquiry he needs to
testify before Congress and we need to
bring in Jack besobic reported that some
of the people involved are willing to
testify against them so we'll see what
happens let's read some of these chats
smash that like button if you haven't
already and don't forget bonus segment
at timcast.com Matthew Hammond says with
a borg turning against Nicki Minaj do
you think her world view was shattered
will she join Kanye at his Sunday
service singing gospel music I hope so I
don't know about all that wasn't Nikki
one of those people on that bed with
that award that everyone was complaining
about probably however remember like
that that really gratuitous bed was she
wearing gold and the women were like on
the bed booty dancing or whatever and
conservative she was in tight gold let's
just say Nikki's not one for you know
did she do that uh um rap song yeah I
think so was that her yeah yeah so when
when folks on the writer like cheering
the fact that Millie Millie has gone to
the left and Minaj has gone to the right
I'm not exactly sure that that's the
case that's fair point not exactly sure
that's the case
all right let's see we got here so many
discussions baby leg Bennett says Biden
says Millie is a patriot this begs the
question who's more patriotic Millie or
Benedict Arnold Christian great question
all right Stephen Frost says I just had
to quit my job over vaccine mandates out
of principle my Integrity is more
important than them meeting a quota for
me you know we got to I talk about
chickens all the time because we have
eight babies now we had originally six
chickens we adopted one chicken it was
older than the others now they've had a
bunch of babies and we've got five
they're called black stars and we've got
three uh three others that are just you
know Rhode Island red and an Easter
egger and Leghorn Rhode Island red those
are we only have one rooster and there's
something real special about growing
your own food eating your own cherry
tomatoes and peppers in the morning and
I tell you
people get addicted to easy City living
you're sitting there in your apartment
you're hungry you press a few buttons
boom Pizza shows up that's bad for us
I think people would greatly benefit by
rolling up their sleeves going out every
morning I go out after my first segment
I record I go out and tend to the
chickens I check their food I'll check
their water check the eggs open up the
the free range thing so they can come
out and party and do chicken stuff I
water the plants then I you know do a
walk around the house go back in and get
back to work I've got this friend who
does like zero waste sustainability I
was thinking about flying her out here
someday and doing that here doing like a
gray water system or something yeah big
time also when you cook I cooked we did
a show in the cast castle where I cooked
a delicious stew and uh the scraps I
threw away didn't even think about
feeding them the chickens in the
comments people were like you can feed
the vegetable scraps to the chickens
yeah just throw your food got to make
sure that the specific vegetables are
okay for the specific environment I
watched Thomas Massey's uh little
documentary about his Homestead in
Kentucky and he said something that
stood out to me is like between we don't
compost anything he's like between the
chickens and the dogs they eat
everything yeah or they'll eat the bugs
that climb on it yeah all right let's
see
uh Baba Tyler Toth with a throwback says
it's said that Knowles's color is still
half popped out to this day ah I believe
it last time Michael was here one collar
was sticking out of his sweater or
whatever I can't believe I didn't notice
I felt terrible he's an animal all right
let's see slavkai says where is Ian's
new show The Joy of Cooking he's giving
off some Bob Ross Vibes and his love of
cookies is nostalgic love you you pseudo
hippie uh it is on the way is it called
The Joy of Cooking I think that's where
we're going yeah
pseudo hippie you have guests we'll have
that many multiple hosts it'll be gonna
be a fantastic time nutrition sharp
knives and a safe cutting geez yeah I'm
gonna fix my technique why aren't they
giving you your full hippie do yeah the
big the big fro but why are you a pseudo
hippie
I think because it's 2000 2021 yeah
dippies are old Christopher hunt says is
Young Money red pilled Lil Wayne
supported Trump Nikki says something
sensible we just need Drake to talk
about the Border crisis Young Money
That's what I'm saying man she's
affiliated with some red pill guys
people that like Trump people that are
going to advocate for some issues that
are going to rub the Liberals the wrong
way she's on the wrong team according to
them Samantha Dragon says Ian need to
look at the uranium short squeeze it's
happening now brought on by a first of
its kind Sprott physical holding really
interesting short squeeze what was the
last thing uh
Sprott how do you spell s-p-r-o-t-t
Eric Miller says tomato is a fruit but
it doesn't belong in a fruit salad
vaccines are great but not for everyone
imagine if Trump mandated hcq yeah I
think uh
I think vaccines are for mostly
everybody you know for the most part I
think the real issue is regardless of my
or anyone's opinion
if I talk to somebody you know and trust
and don't let people get in in between
and the problem I have with YouTube
censorship is that the left is allowed
to get in between people and their
doctors but the right isn't
that's dumb go find a good doctor talk
to him they'll tell you what's up yep
I'm getting tested text messages from
people saying it was a good run on Tim
cast bro I thought you I thought what
you were saying was really powerful I
enjoyed listening to it because a lot of
people are going through what you're
going through yeah no they're just
joking because they don't understand
that like when we fight and argue about
stuff it's because we're just we're like
we're just we're doing it are they
implying I'm gonna throw you out yeah
yeah we're done we're done just gave you
very expensive just because we were
arguing about something and it gets
heated people like it was a good run on
zipcasting mate I'm blowing up I'm
blowing up I'll have it I'll have an
even better whiskey for you next time
yeah man I want to be here for a Joy of
Cooking but you might want to look into
uh
trademarks on that oh yeah because you
said it out loud I think it was the
Julie Childs book yeah I think it's the
famous I'm not set I'm not stuck on a
name yeah
the good times of cooking yeah I like it
all right all right
sad saddo Warrior says you guys talked
about the Stanford Prison Experiment
recently and that experiment has been
highly discredited the guards were
coached to be cruel and some moments
where uh acted rather uh some moments
were acted rather than real yeah that's
what I was saying I thought that
Stanford thing was was was was bunk
interesting it may be bunk but you've
seen it happen in people though yeah
definitely you see people get drunk with
power
you see people like rule follow to
tyranny yep X says dude quit ripping on
vosh I understand the contradiction with
libertarian socialism but he's a good
guest fascinating conversations Target
him less please no
he's welcome to be a guest I'm grateful
that he that he's come on the couple
times he he has I am not going to
refrain from criticizing people because
I'm worried about not having them as
guests so uh Joe Rogan and Tim Dillon I
criticize them you know over the the
performing at vaccine mandated venues
and I really don't think Joe's gonna be
like I'll never have Tim pull back I
hate that guy because I said you know
like I'm critical of this I'm pretty
sure he's gonna be like you know
whatever you know what I mean yeah I've
had actually some of my best
interactions with people are after I
criticized them heavily about something
that they knew you know that's the thing
is that when when the thing what you're
saying about Tim Dylan he knows what
what you're saying has some validity
it's not like you're you're totally
missing the marks honestly Tim at risk
of not getting that good scotch in two
weeks I gotta say that I think he had a
valid point which is I'm touring all
over the place
the people in this jurisdiction voted
for the people that enacted the mandates
and they support it
if you don't want to go to that show
don't go to that show it's sort of a
very libertarian approach in a sense
it's like I'm gonna do it you can take
it or leave it I'll go over here too
it's not like he's almost don't pretend
like you're against them right but it's
not like he's only exclusively going to
places that are vaccinated why didn't he
go to Jersey City that's a good question
do they have a venue big enough for his
giant head there are there are I mean so
the point I made the other day is
perhaps he's already entered into
contracts and not the mandates are out
it's like well look I had the
opportunity to do an event in New York
City and and subject my people to the
vax mandates and I decided to do it in
Jersey City jackbrunch.com 926 21 come
on down it's gonna be a great show
simple that was my decision that was my
choice and you know I just didn't want
to deal with it and I didn't want to
give them the tax money into New York
City I don't need to have a venue with a
thousand people in it I don't need to
perform in front of a large group of
people and I would be willing to
sacrifice my comfort for my principles
but what if what if there was a thousand
vaccinated people that wanted to see you
and they'd all be willing to pay for you
to come to this place where they
required vaccines nope you wouldn't do
it even though they all wanted it and
they were willing to pay it would not no
one was coerced wouldn't do it
interesting yep wouldn't do it
nope ain't gonna happen you know Tim
you're awfully principled I enjoy that
about you yeah it makes for good arguing
to an extent I think the important thing
to point out is like a really good uh
argument was um talking about like vax
mandates for like this uh gender-based
discrimination versus race
discrimination and how we tolerate one
but don't tolerate the other even though
the arguments presented in law are the
same yes it's not so much about
principles for the most part it's about
like um moral Frameworks so you can you
can look at a structure and be like I
think segregation is wrong and then they
say the 1964 Civil Rights Act says you
can't discriminate on the basis of race
or gender and thus you can't have racial
segregation but we can have gender
gender segregation so there's an
interesting question there and then
people say well there's a biological
difference between men and women and
then race realists say oh but there's a
biological uh difference between
different races and then you get into
the semantic the scientific argument
when people say oh races are a social
construct and then all of a sudden
you're all over the place yeah and so
that's why I'm kind of like is it really
principles or is it you know being
obstinate you know what I mean yeah yeah
there are some things I won't do I think
some things are right or something's
wrong but so we can add to dumb and
diabolical we can add to principled or
obstacles yeah great game it's tough
isn't it
uh yeah yeah a little bit a little bit
challenging yeah
all right case closed 93 says I'm an IRS
officer who watches your show and you
need to understand unpaid taxes are a
civil violation not a criminal one also
since we can't lean Levy unpaid
Obamacare I doubt we could do it for the
vaccines
good point I suppose
um I'll tone that one down a bit and say
they may they may come out and be like
you're trying to obfuscate the point I'm
making is if they really want to enforce
them against you they will find a means
through the law to do it unpaid taxes or
avoiding taxes when you try to obfuscate
the stuff is where you get into the
criminal territory and they could argue
oh you're trying to hide the fact that
you're doing X Y or Z but um more
importantly the enforcement doesn't need
to come from the IRS in terms of them
showing up and arresting you
shutting down your business and seizing
your your your your your funds is one
way they could do it but you know maybe
maybe not
unvaccinated Soldier says serious
question Jack how do you wear a mask
with that epic beard you know what's
very interesting you should say that uh
they make me wear one it goes like this
and then it comes up over my chin and it
gives me beard mask mask beard mask
beard like uh beard uh oh that's fine do
you have a picture of the mass beard no
because it's horrible
um
I only wear a mask and where I'm
essentially required to do it where I
can't get on a plane otherwise uh and I
got a beard mask it just it hangs down
flat oh that is awesome Yep yeah I gotta
get a photo of that yeah I got in my
pocket all right just pull it out no
show us you have the master yeah give us
a glimpse it was in my it was in my car
and I just happened to grab it I
literally don't wear it anywhere but oh
you know what I did wear it today I take
that back I had a doctor's appointment
I had to go to the doctor
in a doctor's office in Maryland you're
required to wear a mask they gave me the
choice between health care and wearing a
mask yep and I picked a mask every time
it sucked but here we go there it is
it's like a pair it's a big diaper it's
so weird on my it sucks that's cool
looking yeah all right Noel peabone says
I get the argument Tim's making though
20 years from now if we live in a real
dictatorship you can look back and say
at least my kids got to play sports
uh yeah
I'm thinking of it from their
perspective I know we probably already
went over this but I feel like 16 14
you're an adult I know legally or not
but psychologically I knew what I wanted
when I was 14. if my dad took away my
opportunity to become an actor because
of his politics I would have hated him
never forgave him and probably become a
raging alcoholic and killed myself or
something yeah Joe spinella says Tim say
no to YouTube and their censorship by
ending your show on their platform guess
what you won't you support their system
by cooperating in it well there's a big
difference between the the government
mandating something by decree in
violation of our our laws and our courts
and our branches of government and a
large multinational unaccountable
corporation
shutting people down and violating
fundamental rights the difference is
there is an argument to be made about
what we have a right to do I don't think
YouTube should be censoring anybody but
YouTube also provides free services to
people so there's an argument between
what YouTube is it should be allowed to
do what they should be allowed to do in
this instance I think it's a call for
regulation our our politician should
come in and intervene to stop YouTube
from doing these things and we need
legislative action to prevent this no
one has come to me by executive decree
mandating like I violate my bodily
autonomy in this regard more importantly
though uh you're wrong we are actively
building timcast.com and slowly removing
our Reliance on the platform you may
have noticed at the beginning of the
year I cut the amount of content I
produce in half on YouTube and we
started producing more content on
timcast.com so yes the ultimate goal is
I will get off of YouTube as they
escalate their unconscionable Behavior
that being said wearing a mask I don't
think wearing masks are that big of a
deal when a private business says it I
don't like government mandates but if I
go to a local store and I have to go
there and the private business owner is
like no shirt no shoes no mask no
service I put a mask on about the doctor
the doctor uh same thing like it's those
are private practices
doctors are private practice
to varying degrees there are there are
differences a mask is something you put
on your face and look I don't like the
mask mandates when people have to work
for eight hours you know that's that's
brutal when it's like I'm going into a
building for 15 or 20 minutes and it's
the the person who works there is
wanting me to do it or whatever and if I
have a choice to go somewhere else I'll
walk next door and go somewhere else if
I have a choice between going Maryland
Virginia or West Virginia because I do I
go to West Virginia where you can do
whatever you want there's no mandates go
play pool don't need a mask don't need
to get vaccinated you do whatever you
want we went to we went to Virginia and
a lot of places mandate masks and some
places
strongly recommend them and so I'm just
kind of like it's a minor inconvenience
it's a it's it's a bad move in a bad
Direction I will actively do my best to
speak out against them and seek out
businesses that are more upholding of
freedoms but there's a big difference
between a private establishment and a
government mandate you know what I mean
so if Google all these companies are
mandating vaccines I think it's a bad
thing we should speak out against
it's not the same as Joe Biden violating
the branches of government and our and
you know how our country functions
except for the fact that the federal
government has an office in the white
house where they coerce the social media
companies into censoring content that
they find objectionable that's correct
so the corporations are doing the
bidding of the government therefore when
you adhere to the corporations uh you
know mandates you're actually adhering
to the government mandates and you're
subjecting yourself to Fascism so in in
our instance we have created timcast.com
and the members only segments as sort of
our Speakeasy so that we can stand in
this place and be like hey everybody if
you want to hear the things YouTube
would ban us for we've set them up in a
place where we're moving our business
timcast.com is a bigger portion of the
business now than YouTube Ever Was and I
cut my content down by half so I'll be
you know trying to be reasonable there
are some things that become hard lines
like inject yourself with this yeah and
I don't necessarily mean the vaccines I
mean when someone comes to you and says
violate your bodily autonomy okay well
hold on there a minute sir like let's
have I don't know if I'm you can't go
back you can't go backwards from that
yeah YouTube's censoring people is
something I've long pushed back against
and then ultimately ultimately decided
let's start getting away from YouTube
which is why we use Rumble all of our
content is up on Rumble all of it and
bit shoot and minds and it's also why I
stopped producing half the content I did
because I don't want to ban this
platform so it's not yeah not an
overnight shutdown
but our intent absolutely is to move to
timcast.com and the fediverse you're
always going to have centralized
services that censor that is the nature
of humanity and that is necessary for us
to survive is to have local private
places and things where you can dictate
the rules of what can and can't happen
so we're building the fediverse out so
that we have a decentralized system that
can function alongside all these
centralized systems I think indeed JP
mclone says Tim is right the pilot
wanted to enforce the policy more than
he wanted to lose his job why is it hard
for others to acknowledge as fact and
that's that's my point
Rosie Riveter says Tim can't ask Jack to
pull his kids from baseball until he's
willing to violate YouTube's censorship
policies to take a principal stand
against tyranny
I'm not entirely sure what
opinion I'm not allowed to have on
YouTube that I'm being censored of like
there are certain words we can't say
that are slurs that we don't even swear
on this show anyway although we did
swear this time but we like hey guys
don't swear we try to we try to keep
things sorry guys
lit whatever happened tonight was
awesome it was so fun to be here so
there's like uh
the one issue though is I want to have a
conversation with Steve Bannon about his
opinions on the election you can't do
that on YouTube so what do we do
leverage YouTube to create a space where
we can have those conversations
not a perfect solution but as I already
stated just I want to make sure I'm
lever I'm leveraging baseball into
turning my son into you know a virtuous
man
do you have options
there are some but for him this seems to
be the best option
the issue is as much as we are trying to
get ourselves off of YouTube and we have
slowly been doing so
the issue is YouTube has used their
monopolistic power to dominate the space
yeah and there is no other option yeah
we do use Rumble mines bit shoot and put
our content up on there and uh it's not
as effective as driving people to
timcast.com but ultimately we're
producing more and more content for
timcast.com with the ultimate goal of
creating a website that doesn't need to
be on YouTube because screw the
censorship screw the censorship so uh I
think I'll put it this way it would be
unreasonable to end this overnight when
I'm not when I'm when I'm still on the
battlefield
there's a big difference between it
coming to a point where there's going to
be a hard stop where they look at your
kid and say
take the shot while you're out that's
that's literally staying at the edge of
the cliff making a decision yeah for
this it's kind of like hey this is a big
problem we're facing let's move do our
best to to move away from this as fast
we can yeah so they're not they're not
one for one I respect the argument
however and yes let me assure you we are
actively trying to get off YouTube and
we have been doing so and I'll say it
one more time timcast.com is a bigger
portion of our business than YouTube
Ever Was and by cutting down the content
I produced in half I lost a ton of money
I didn't need to do that
but I did
because I didn't want to because I'm
like you know we're gonna we're gonna
start I'm gonna stop producing this
stuff for YouTube we're gonna start
focusing on building a different
business
to make something better so we've got
members only content coming up for the
cast Castle Vlog members only content
coming up called The Green Room we've
got a new show that is going to be on
you know podcast platforms and we're
putting all of the core stuff we're
trying to make our own version of like
Netflix that's the end result we'll
leverage those systems the best of our
ability in the meantime but we're
actively trying to get up are you on the
Green Room tonight that's why I chuckled
when he said we're doing the Green Room
I was like yep I remember yeah I walk in
the door they hand me a bottle of scotch
and a camera gets put in my face yep get
ready for it next time I'm gonna have to
come in like prepared for that usually
I'm not I'm I'm gonna come in I'm like
let me get warmed up etc etc I was all I
was on immediately more of that I was on
immediately so there's there's a lot of
uh comments from people saying I'll read
one more because I don't want to read
the same things over and over again
James Nelson says I have five kids Tim
is right this is a chance to teach your
kids principles of Freedom are more
important than one season of baseball to
be fair I don't think you're talking I
think you're talking about a career it's
a whole entire career it's entire
Varsity Sports and National Collegiate
Athletic Association which is the
Gateway into a million different things
it's not one season bruh Emily mower
says if everyone pulled their kids out
of sports then things would change now
again I'm just reading some of these
because there's a lot that go back and
forth the next one says Tim you would
lose your livelihood and not be able to
feed your kids on principle but you will
willingly censor yourself on YouTube
frustration is understandable I
appreciate what you do but you bend like
everyone else
so I want to make sure I'll read those
criticisms as much as you know the
people agree with me that people
disagree with me I do think they're
different in the sense that
if you get off YouTube right now if
every single person Crowder and me stick
sex and Hammer said okay we're done
we're off YouTube then the entire
Battlefield is just seated to the left
because this is where the ideological
conflict is happening
if someone came to me and said if if
Google emailed me and said send in proof
of vaccination or you're banned from
YouTube I would be banned from YouTube
and I would get in my van and go down by
the river uh or I would just start
producing all of my content on
timcast.com and then take a more
traditional route but let me put it very
very simply
if I was forced to have a vaccine
mandate or shut my company down
I would shut my company down if I was
forced to do testing I would shut my
company down I would I would I would
resign and quit in whatever capacity I
am beholden to nobody else nobody no
secret billionaire has given me anything
I can shut it all down whenever I want
and if Google emails me right now and
says provide proof of vaccination for
you and your staff or you are banned I
would say ban me
two seconds and I gotta tell you part of
it would be a great relief
people don't seem to understand this you
know
I want to make sure people understand
something because I'm not saying this to
brag and a lot of people may take it
that way
I am by no means poor and I don't need
to work I do this because I want to
because I believe in it because it needs
to be done and we need to build
timcast.com
other we have two non-profits we have
the fediverse nonprofit to create
unbannable open source networking
Technologies when you become a member at
timcast what do we have we have Ian and
crew on calls every single day working
to build out this non-profit not for
money we've also already filed the
paperwork for a fact-checking non-profit
not to make money because these things
need to happen
in the event that I actually got banned
I wouldn't just take a van down by the
river I'd put my feet up in a hammock
except some pina coladas you would
triple down on Tim cast I mean that's
just you that's my take of you and your
personality but like if if the if the
domain hosts if like the providers if if
all of our you know data centers and
they all said show us proof or you're
out I'd be out yeah and I'd be like I'm
gonna plant some vegetables and you know
eat eggs
I would be like it's not happening and
you know there's the Big Challenge right
that's an effective way to excise people
from the ideological conflict but ten
years ago Tim would have a totally
different perspective I would have yeah
no I wouldn't have what do you mean ten
years ago you wouldn't have the same
perspective of ban me off of all the
stuff I'll just put my feet up and count
my money no you would have been put my
feet up and be hungry
right 10 years ago you weren't Rich dude
10 10 years ago
uh I I suppose I suppose the issue here
isn't isn't about having money
like when I was homeless at 18. I wasn't
never I never cried about it I there was
not one day where I was like this is the
worst life imaginable I was like almost
mentioned well you knew it was temporary
no I didn't yeah you did no I didn't
you're a capable competent person you
knew that you were on your way somewhere
else and that was a passing moment
that's that's never been my frame of
mind my frame of mind has always been
really at that time on the bench you
thought you were a homeless loser
destined to be living in the streets the
rest of your life I never I never said
to myself I'm a homeless loser Destin
live on the streets of course not I
wonder where I'll sleep tomorrow right
so I didn't say my friend my good friend
Ed Lattimore made this point very
clearly there's a distinction between
being broke and being poor
there's a poor State of Mind
there's a broke is a passing moment that
was a passing moment for you well I have
a friend from from Mexico and he said
broken that was his word for broke I'm
broken right now I can't I'm broken and
it was very painful to hear that because
it felt like emotionally he was yeah
yeah you can be broken it's different
than being poor Justin Green says Thomas
Paine had no surviving children so
there's a good point we made and that's
another Point too if your kids don't
make it then there's then you've lost
already your kids are the future so if
you can't if you don't have good kids to
survive then
yeah but uh just on that point
every step of my life
I was always just like gotta do what I
got to do yeah I was never alike one day
looking up at the stars like I will have
it all never
no dreams it wasn't about dreams it was
about like I'm gonna do stuff
and so every day I wake up and I'm
thinking about what am I gonna do today
they're they're like so the story I tell
about the journalists not wanting to
give up their apartment I when I worked
for vice and I was doing these big you
know documentaries we did the kim.com
one got like five million views
overnight and people were like oh man
he's so lucky it's like I was sleeping
on my friend's couch I was sleep on a
couch in Williamsburg for 300 bucks a
night at an Ever room it was it was
difficult I hope it wasn't at night bro
I'm sorry that's a rip per month I would
wake up my my my my my homie would be
smoking weed and he'd be like sitting in
his living room and so he'd be like he'd
be chilling and I'd just be like groggy
and like totally whacked out like this
is so difficult but uh you got to do
what you got to do you know and so and
that that's an excellent uh cost benefit
analysis and investment in yourself and
these choices that we make When We're
Young when you've got nothing to lose
and that's the time to take risks time
to double down time to be poor or
passing broke moment without a poor
mindset because you know there's
something bigger coming
something bigger coming you know just
just earlier when we were talking before
the show not to call you out dude but
you did say 10 years ago you're like I
knew all this was coming I had dreams so
let me yeah so I'll explain that when I
was 16 I went to some hippie commune
where they had a big 1600 square foot
like 20 foot ceilings so it was like
this one room and they were like
everybody pitches in 100 bucks a month
and we have this big space with a mini
ramp in it that's what I knew was coming
that's what I knew I was going to do I
was going to get the space and it's
another story I told where I went to
bunch of my friends like hey let's get
this space let's build a mini ramp if
everyone pitches in 100 bucks and they
were like build it and then we'll see
what we do so it wasn't that I expected
to be wealthy I expected to be free I
always knew that no matter what happened
I'd be sitting there being like life's
fun yeah you know there there was like
there's a period where uh
I just drove when I was uh like in my
early 20s I went to Seattle I went to
Denver I went to uh eventually went to
Los Angeles and I just
did whatever you know life it's crazy to
me life is fun I never understood you
know people who uh become so depressed
and hate their lives
they would end it because I'm like man
you just giving yourself carb lunch
you've got no worries like you think
it's worthless and it's over you can't
do it like now you can do anything
because nothing matters right if you
guys know whatever you've got nothing
left to lose that's actually a very
freeing moment
yeah so I remember one day I had an
apartment I just like got up and left
I had an apartment in Chicago and I went
to my roommates and I was just like I'm
gonna take a car ride to California then
what I don't know I got 200 bucks sounds
like fun
and then I went to California and I you
know got lucky plan to sleep on the
beach but didn't look until you have
kids everything you're doing is that 200
ride to California my friend just FYI
all right Austin uh Aries says maybe
it's time to return to Monkey exiting
society and being self-sufficient seems
to be a little extreme but seems options
are becoming Limited homesteading
find yourself some you know you know
what's crazy you know we were just
looking at 500 what was it five 600
acres of land 600 for half a mill oh
yeah that's a very good price 100 acres
in West Virginia I'm telling you dude
West Virginia is the is is is is oh we
were both like he's gonna open the chest
and show them where it is don't say it
West Virginia is the place to go
everyone should move there do it now
don't say that yet what we're saying is
if you say it out loud everyone's going
out there and change it it's basically
Virginia is like
it's like uh it's it's this this Valley
you know you make it through the ancient
tomb into this Lost Valley and there's
like pterodactyls and you're like where
am I and there's these massive avocados
you pick you're like it's so big there's
we got pawpaw everywhere but you're
saying West Virginia is like legit and
amazing un kind of untapped state
West Virginia is the place where you can
buy a decent parcel of land in the
middle of nowhere with no access to
utilities where you'll never talk to
your friends again and you can have
chickens goats and grow vegetables and
work hard every day and fight off bears
and starlink hey man when that happened
adults Gulch F IRL that whole thing you
just described
plus starlink is my heaven on Earth bro
I think people should
do that I'm doing it and you can do it
whatever state for the most part uh I
like West Virginia because land is cheap
and you can go uh into Central West
Virginia and find a couple acres for
like a hunt with a house on it for 100
grand and then you've got your chickens
you got your goats your water Wyoming
also is pretty amazing right now
especially for crypto law mountainous
but good West Virginia it is literally
called the mountain state but the
mountains in Wyoming are very different
from the mountains in West Virginia
indeed there people people come out here
and they're like the Blue Ridge
Mountains are those are even Mountains
they're mountains but they're covered in
trees they're mountains I was just in
Western North Carolina
is beautiful those are beautiful the
Blue Ridge is beautiful absolutely
Robert Poynter says Jack totally with
you point a gun at me and I can say
screw you pointed at my kid and it's
completely different kids is a giant
paradigm shift I didn't get until he
became a father yeah you're making me
not want to have kids my God no that's a
testament to how important and valuable
too much to throw away man I can't I
can't risk that them for this
waffle Sensei says Luke has been winning
all the arguments in the chat tonight
yeah Luke was supposed to be here a long
time ago Luke wait he's coming back to
the studio supposed to be oh yeah oh
he's Luke no does you never have to sit
over there now no no no
new studio the new table plenty of space
that's a hell of a table I saw the table
I was like ETA one week all right so
Luke no for the table no for the taste
of the studio okay yeah yeah so uh the
construction crew has already started on
chicken City
and that means they're they're pulling
guys off of Studio construction because
now it's down to like getting the table
done yeah the table is impressive so
beautiful and so they said uh probably
about one week and that means after that
week we have to do camera mounting
no lighting required why the whole
ceiling is lined with LEDs incredible
it's so balanced okay I'll take these I
need a couple more and we can still we
can still dim them in on both sides and
change it and we're going to do a strip
in the middle for for lighting faces but
so uh all we gotta we might wall mount
the cameras but once the table is done
it is basically good to go we need art
that's going to be an issue we'll hang
some stuff up uh but I think new studio
will be ready to go very soon sick can't
wait Luke
so why I go downstairs and we have a
receptionist we have a mail room
and there are boxes that are very heavy
and therefore Luke Rudd and they're
bullets oh and you sent them here to my
house
you know what it was it was Biden banned
Russian Imports of ammo so Luke was like
and then like we got a bunch there's six
tons
yeah in the driveway right the whole
room no Luke's probably mad that I just
said that uh there's some other stuff I
don't know all right let's see we'll
we'll uh we'll we'll do a shout out for
rumble because um yeah man I'm on Rumble
yeah I can certainly respect the
criticisms over being on a platform that
uh censors people and me not just
shutting the show down but uh I have cut
half of my Showdown and we are moving as
much as we can to timcast.com as quickly
as we can uh like I said timcast.com you
know one of the stupidest things I did
was try and turn YouTube into a business
from the beginning I should have started
timcast.com with member content and
articles and I could have and I just did
not well no I think maybe the upside is
YouTube is free marketing like they they
push your stuff and they push you hard
well no they didn't they
no we're in a bubble the algorithms are
isolated but they lifted you out of it
you know your stuff the algorithms
picked you up and pushed you to a huge
market so that helped in the early days
it uh I would say yes definitely not as
much as you might think not enough to
make it worth it so I greatly regret
that we didn't launch a rudimentary
timcast.com two years ago I had I had my
website with some stuff Auto popping up
on it and I never created the the
premium member stuff that I should have
and uh it took us a week
from launching timcast.com to have it be
the dominant portion of the business
and I'm like wow I remember that I
remember we were like we're launching
this then I come back two weeks later
and we're like this is what happened I
was like
should have done it a long time ago but
you know what look like YouTube is the
equivalent of a Blog
that's just content marketing that you
use to just sort of create a secondary
thing and I think it's hard in
retrospect to look back and be like I
should have done this should have done
that when you know it's all worked out
pretty well it is but I I you know in in
terms of principle I could have made a
faster move to get away from YouTube and
for advice for anyone starting out now
or working now start your own thing and
start taking directions from the user to
you subscriptions so you cut out the
middleman and the fediverse is coming
down this is this is why another
nonprofit that we're setting up is going
to create free and open source
networking subscription website software
so you don't have to be beholden to
anybody and no one can ban you okay look
this is very valuable information but
like guys if you're out there actually
starting to try to create if you have no
one listening to you you're not gonna
have anybody to sign up to your premium
stuff yeah you got to do it all together
you've got to use YouTube you've got to
use all these markets all of them
Facebook ads if you got to do that
Twitter start your minds account get
your Rumble going and start your own
website where you take subscriptions I
do think it's fair to leverage the
platform forms of your political Rivals
to gain
access but brilliant yeah so anyway
we've gone a little long we got to do
the member segment I'll just do one more
shout out oh my gosh Janet Partridge
says Rumble now has super chat with
their live stream would you consider
live streaming on Rumble we are planning
uh it's just it comes down to the
development side on our website because
again we want to we want to do that we
don't want to sacrifice the the
battlefield that is YouTube and the in
the in the culture War because it is the
biggest platform and that would be
foolish but we also don't want to be
providing resources to YouTube
um disproportionately benefiting them
while they're actively participating in
the culture War so that being said go to
timcast.com be a member because not only
are you supporting the journalists who
are hiring and I think we're up to like
seven or eight now but you're also
supporting the nonprofit work that we're
starting to we're going to be launching
and then once the nonprofit's launched
formally because I've just basically
been paying for it out of my personal
pocket once they launched then we can
contribute like our company puts we'll
put money in there and then people can
start doing more and more work but the
work is being done because people are
doing it for passion uh you can follow
me at timcast you can follow the show at
timcast IRL Jack you've got some stuff
to shout out I do we are doing a jack
brunch tour you know why because we all
need food folks and fun we're doing a
Sunday social for those of us on the
right side of things whichever way you
want to interpret that word right those
of us on the right side of things come
out break bread with us drink some wine
with us New York we're going to Jersey
City because screw those vax mandates in
New York City 926 we're going to Tampa
10 and sometime in early October we're
going to Nashville uh that's 10 10 we're
going to Nashville 10 24 go to
jackbrunch.com follow us on Twitter at
Jack brunch hope to see you there I'll
be there live in person we'll have a
great time very cool did you shout out
Jack Murphy live Jack Murphy live on
Twitter and on YouTube we are it's
pretty epic 140 000 followers on Twitter
comes so far I keep touching everyone's
want to see like in five years ago you
started five years now you've created
like an I mean essentially it's it's not
an Empire it's the budding of the Empire
it is it's not quite a Tim cast right
when I sit next to Tim it's like this
Empire Kingdom but let's say I'm content
and and the positive impact that we're
having on the world the individuals that
we're touching that's what it's all
about thank you yeah uh Ian Crossland
peace and love follow that guy check out
my new cooking shots coming soon it
won't be called The Joy of Cooking no
Ian's Crazy Kitchen okay that'll be good
that's actually with two K's two crazy
kitchens yeah perfect I love it you guys
should follow me on Twitter but before I
tell you where to follow me I will say
that sometimes I get this uh why are you
guys on YouTube you're playing their
game whatever I love the idea of using
YouTube to direct people over to our
website I think that's brilliant and I
love the idea of using their own tools
against somebody that's some Jiu Jitsu
right okay let's call it we've built a
bridge that funnels people off of you is
this one this is what I was being
criticized for in the mainstream media
when they when they started slamming our
website they were like he's creating a
funnel off of YouTube's safe space into
conspiracy BS and stuff radicalizing yes
so at least there's that but uh uh did
you shout out your no I didn't you guys
can follow me for more hot takes like
that at Sour Patch Lids as I attempt to
gain more followers and Sour Patch Kids
please that's all I care about
timcast.com member segment should be up
around 11 or so pm and we will see you
all there bye guys